two
welcome back to the number 12 podcast in
the world
number 12 for a reason baby
and we're coming we're going higher
oh
let's get it
started
i want to check
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there in the middle oh thank you yes
it's like a beatles song you know how
they change it up they're famous for
doing that right yeah it's a beautiful
thing they do throwing a curveball
were you inspired inspired by the
beatles in making that yeah i listened
to a bunch of sgt pepper that's cool
yeah yeah remind me of that album
welcome everybody it is july 6th
i am back from covid
um i'm wearing listen i just want to say
this up front
it's been 10 days since i got sick so
technically it's been 10 days since i
got it
everybody said i die but i made it
um
it's been 10 days since i felt ill
according to the cdc you don't even have
to wear a mask after 10 days
but out of an abundance of caution
i'm just going to wear it today your
mask is making me uncomfortable yeah
shut the [ __ ] up tucker it's not about
you please take off your mask bro listen
i'm just being considerate of my
employees
this got nothing to do with you stupid
idiot call the police immediately
bro what
should i take it off i'm making tucker
uh making him uncomfortable
yeah i think but i think the problem i
got i think i got respiratory damage to
be totally honest with you guys
great my lungs are pretty effed up and
so i have a cough still
a pretty severe cough you know i've been
coughing so much i feel like
i feel like i was about to get sick
again last night from coughing so much
um
just like tearing up my throat
but you know anyway i don't i'm not
contagious but i just be i'm just being
uh careful for all the play pimps and
players in here
so anyway welcome back guys um [ __ ]
people saying you're muzzled
i'm muzzled
goddamn putting this mask on me ain't
never again boy oh
can you how's the audio though cause i
was i don't know does it sound a little
messed up or is it fine i mean you're
definitely muffled but
mr babb says no chance that mask stays
on the entire time
[Laughter]
well that's maybe fair
well
anyway we'll see what like
we'll see how much energy i have because
i'll tell you what bro i am so fatigued
too i had to take a break going up those
stairs because like
it feels like you walked up like
three flights of stairs when you went up
half of one it's been hard man kovitz
sucks so bad you guys like seriously
don't get it it sucks so [ __ ] bad
and i'll tell you what even sucks more
i got on my [ __ ] birthday to a
wedding i didn't even want to [ __ ] go
to which i was very vocal about here i
said it's on my birthday i don't want to
go to this [ __ ] wedding
uh i've been happy to go to this wedding
all month and not only did it ruin my
birthday it ruined my whole [ __ ]
month so i go to the wedding
[Music]
been dodging covet for two years folks
two years come back
oops got [ __ ] coveted not only that
ilaga kovid bruce scott kovid our
five-month-old
theodore i don't know how he didn't get
it
it was a miracle you know once we all
started testing positive we sent
theodore
to stay with some family members
and um
he didn't get it he didn't get coleman i
i suspect he might have gotten it
already because he has been pretty sick
this year
well he's been at school with other kids
and stuff but how did we not catch it
from him then it's just i don't know
i mean how did he's not vaccinated
either how how was ian the only one to
catch it
uh a few weeks ago and everybody else
got off scot-free you know well yeah you
could say well
yeah i lived with cam while he had
coveted right
yes sam too i mean sam's a survivor
two-time survivor huh
i'm i think i'm immune i don't know you
got that natural we got to harvest your
blood and study it can i get some of
your blood sam i'm sorry can i get some
of your blood yeah okay duh sure
[ __ ] the vaccine i was gonna shoot sam's
blood up i mean
get those antibodies the blood of god
yeah the worst part so i felt sick first
and i was super sick man
the first night it was just me sick
i was running a fever i was delusional i
was
taking a bunch of like nyquil and all
that like tylenol [ __ ] extra flu [ __ ]
and i also i gotta i gotta tell you guys
you gotta be careful with those drugs
this [ __ ] hit hard as [ __ ]
i don't think you're supposed to mix
those with some of the psychiatric
medicine i take
oh
like lexapro or wellbutrin now
interesting
and i was like not doing good man i was
tripping balls and then i started
getting like anxiety like i haven't had
in a while
i think it was those drugs interacting
with my meds so i stopped taking the the
that stuff and i felt better but
yeah i got my ass kicked so you know
it's so sick where you can't even really
enjoy being sick
usually when you're sick you get to veg
out you play video games to watch tv you
say hey you know what
yes i don't feel well but
everybody's gotta [ __ ] treat me like
a baby
everybody feels bad for me everybody's
gotta do everything for me
and i just watched one piece
and trust me there's a thousand episodes
of that [ __ ] i running out of nothing
i'm on episode like 200 by the way
i don't know that one to be it's good
i'm not a weeb enough for for one piece
it's the most popular mango of all time
is it really yeah by far
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah
deservedly so
it's dope man it's good tell you that
yeah it's fun it's good i like it a lot
okay
excuse me that's right you know i'm
gonna really try not to do that in the
mic guys
i'm a professional broadcaster right
absolutely
um
so yeah i was super sick
and i was just kind of sitting there and
i couldn't get comfortable it was
horrible
and then the next day ila got sick
and at the same time
shortly after that bruce got sick
obviously he's not vaccinated he's only
five months old
the worst part about ela getting sick i
was like [ __ ] no
nobody's gonna feel bad for me
[Music]
now eel is sick now like i gotta take
care of myself and i got to feel bad for
her the real tragedy i was really hoping
it would just be me and i could just
enjoy my
my moment
[Music]
i could have a diva moment you know yeah
stay down [ __ ] your baby
[Laughter]
but no i didn't get that
and then when bruce got sick then it was
like okay we gotta
we don't get to enjoy the luxury of
being sick anymore even though we were
both super sick
because bruce was running like 105 fever
for three days straight oh wow god damn
and it was scary it was scary he was
crying non-stop
he wasn't sleep he was just really
really really messed up and i was very
i was very scared honestly i was not
you know we were calling the doctor we
couldn't you can't go to the doctor
because we all had covered bruce had
covet
we swabbed his little nose and did a
rapid test and it came out positive or
like oh my god dude
he got it really bad
i was so messed up
anyway but you know it was just three
really long days of taking care of our
baby
and it was just torture watching him be
so
you know in so much pain
i mean it's [ __ ] up dude you're you're
four to five month old getting covet you
know that's just [ __ ] up
and the whole time i'm cursing that
goddamn wedding i'll tell you what
um
anyway i'm just curious how david's
doing through all this
it's been a hard time you know and i
just really
has anyone has you tweeted anything has
you done you see anything really
i can't imagine what he's going through
that david lane low yeah cricket spring
you were hanging out with the what's his
name alex alex said he didn't mention
anything about david doing no i don't
know i haven't seen him around david in
a while [ __ ]
hmm
i'm worried about him someone check on
him yeah
yeah he's the real victim of this
situation but
ah man actually a lot of people got
kovid the other there was an other
couple of friends of mine from college
who got it
they showed up wearing masks because
they have a newborn
they were the only two people wearing
masks
they both got [ __ ] covered and their
newborn baby got covered as well
yeah and what the [ __ ] dude what's going
on at this wedding
nothing it was all outdoors
huh i mean we were having fun we were
drinking but we were like outdoors and
[ __ ] i mean there was lots of hugging
and stuff yeah
well
but the wedding was actually really nice
like it was nice to check in with like
lots of old buddies from college it was
pretty crazy to see
some of the faces was the guy who
waffle stomped the jizz in the shower
there
the guy that won't full stomp the jizz
in the story that you've told on the
podcast like 10 times
oh the guy that i removed i goofed on
him he didn't actually waffle stomp we
did a prank on him
maybe i'm confusing two stories didn't
you have a roommate that all of his
his goo
always be in the
drain yeah he was there he was there he
was there he got coveted too oh okay
well there you go yeah
he got covered and his wife got covered
i mean it's a super spreader event man
yeah it sounds like and everyone there's
vaccinated too so i don't know what's
going on i don't know what's the end
game anymore with kovid you know
she's like what the [ __ ]
yeah i think it's just our new reality
unfortunately but this is where i'm
going away but this is a [ __ ] up
illness and it's so contagious this is
just what it's like we're all just gonna
be getting covered
it's hard to see i mean with half the
country just completely saying i don't
give a [ __ ] at this point i mean what
what hope do we really have we're not
going to eradicate it it's not going
away so no no what are you what are you
going to do
i don't know how i just helped my
immunity lasts but i got i avoided it
for two years i mean yeah it's a good
run it's a good run buddy
oh my god
yes horrible it was horrible
it was honestly
one of the worst
weeks of my life
and it was so sad theodore had to go
stay with
my brother and sister-in-law
and he had fun with them they went to
disneyland stuff they had a lot of fun
but it was really hard being away from
my son for a week and he was missing us
and oh god it was just it was just
horrible it really was
but bruce is doing better everyone's
doing fine everyone's you know bruce
made a full recovery he's great he's
beautiful he's happy
he's doing awesome so
everybody's fine
and uh we pretty much got through got
through it now but man that really
sucked and i hate missing the show too i
mean what we missed a whole week yep of
the damn show you get banned you get
banned again then you get covered i mean
we haven't done like a full month yeah i
know without interruption
it makes me anxious whenever we skip
like that why i feel like i like lose my
groove i want to stay in it oh yeah
yeah i know what you mean
we got a groove going on here
uh
you know
i'm just hoping i didn't get brain
damage or something you know how they
say long covet and all this [ __ ] like
they go oh people get coveted lose five
iq points whatever [ __ ] they're
peddling now what ian i can confirm that
yeah and you've had it twice so you
probably lost 10 iq points yeah yeah
i think it actually grows i'm probably
like 15. like it's exponential yeah yeah
yeah
brain damage yeah i feel it
oh the other crazy thing
i lost my sense of smell completely
a hundred percent and what was weird
about it was my nose
was super clear like my nasal passages
were clear i could breathe
i could not smell a [ __ ] thing bro
you could put a piece of [ __ ] under my
nostrils i couldn't smell it and i was
really afraid i was going to lose my
sense of smell permanently because
that's another thing you hear i just saw
somebody
in the chat say after they got covered
it took a year
full year for their sense of smell to
come back
it was so weird and then obviously
eating food is not really that fun
when you have no sense of smell
everything tastes just kind of [ __ ]
dull
but i'm happy to say my smell started to
come back really okay which was pretty
fast so i was actually really relieved
uh by that
and i'm hoping that you know it
continues to come back so
that was another thing i was worried
about but yeah i probably lost five iq
points
they go oh people get covered or more
likely to have a
dementia
at an older it's like [ __ ] off bro stop
telling me that [ __ ]
you've seen all that studies
they go people who get covered are more
likely to [ __ ] go
impotent feel like it hasn't been around
long enough to do a study about that
but maybe i don't know but you've seen
that studies it's all this [ __ ] like
people with clover are more likely to
turn into zombies during the apocalypse
and eat the flesh of their fallen
brothers right yeah
brain fog that's another one i'm not
trying to get they go oh people would
cover the [ __ ] brain fog
shut the [ __ ] up stop
stop saying that [ __ ] put those studies
away
does that stuff bother you ian when you
read all that
yeah
i kind of just accept it
really it gives me it makes me anxious i
get all obsessed about it i go did i do
is that stuff happening to me they
obsess anxiously obsess about it maybe i
have some fog already i don't know
but i'm not worried
i want fog
i want clarity
i want clear skies people with kova get
foggy [ __ ] brain damage
you know there's all these negative
effects from kovid
but
i mean this isn't directly covered but
the pandemic has brought some positives
let's not forget face masks make people
look more attractive what do you guys
think i mean we're all getting hotter
baby well of course i look more
attractive it's covering like sixty
percent of my faith yeah
it's the bad part
yeah
let me see myself i probably do look
pretty good
you know yeah i look better for sure for
sure
how about now
yeah i can't even see the double chin it
covers it up precisely it's a lot of
flesh i think you're good extra flesh
yeah
i'm pretty sure i got respiratory damage
though because my lungs are [ __ ] up
recent study finds cover 19 was
associated with the increased risk of
being diagnosed with dementia
six months after infection what the [ __ ]
i can't verify if that's a legitimate
source where did you get it then uh it's
just one of the many uh reports that
came up associated with cognitive
dementia six months is that for old
people or am i asking to go crazy any
minute
is this people
44 to 46 uh-oh
[ __ ] you're not i'm sorry wrong age i
forgot i'm not
yeah who got covered here whose brain's
fogged over
old man
i got a nice gloss over my brain you
know what i'm saying
i got a nice glossy finish over my
[ __ ] brain
this stupid wedding that i never even
wanted to go to
so there you have it hmm
yeah it was horrible but that's
basically it um
well this is me in the basement thanks
cam this is awesome
this was the vibe for sure bro
except i was just in my underwear the
whole time because i was hot
yeah we saw it i posted that tick tock
yeah
i'll actually pull this up for you guys
so this tick tock i got it
i made this tick tock the night it was
the last night where i was the only one
that was sick
and i was like okay you know what i'm
just gonna vibe out here
i'm losing my mind a little bit
oh i can't play the music that sucks
but then like shortly after this ela got
sick bruce got sick and it wasn't fun
anymore
me having covert plus cold medicine
hallucinations and a straight line
i was trapped in the basement
people were leaving food for me on the
stairs like and [ __ ] i had to come out
like a
leper yeah
that's how love did it for me
oh yeah love your cam's caretaker
yep i got uh ubu eats from the streets
up to him and all that stuff
hey i've never had it before i gotta
juice up dude yeah come on
did you ever tell me what you were
getting from taco bell
uh
my favorite was the shumpa lumpus
chicken chalupa
is that a willy wonka dish
yeah yeah yeah yeah some worms in there
and stuff yeah yeah me and love nine
fortnight there's a daily bugle he calls
it the daily bugle
yeah yeah i love it
now but i i'm a mastermind of uber eats
basically i
do the way so i get the most amount of
food for the least amount of price or
the least amount of money
you minimize the delivery fee oh yeah so
sometimes
uh cam can uh
like him
right for me or like he knows i did this
i bought like 50 tacos and i said for
the entire week yeah
did you get the family packs because you
get a family pack a taco for like 20
bucks or something or six even less it's
yeah and as long as you don't get the
crunch you want you can microwave them
it's all good oh
darn garnishing
[Laughter]
anyway let's move on
you know we're all doing better it's
fine
by the way no sponsors today so i would
like to promote
teddyfresh.com if you guys are in the
market for some clothing
it's teddyfresh.com
look at all this good good
good good stuff
i know it's summer but man
this hoodie is so nice
just re reverse fleece hoodie
and
this is a lot of really nice stuff on
that website guys
i don't know i just found this website
guys it's got really amazing clothes i
don't know who making it but
i just think it's so nice martin
yeah i'm doing a team
yo guys i just found this website
teddyfresh.com it's insane dude the
clothes is so nice
and actually i want to announce that we
have a new drop coming out tomorrow
that's the shirt i'm wearing
it's a collaboration with the artist
that gila really loves named gentle
thrills let me show this off for you
guys
oh [ __ ]
it's great
it's all freaked out
oh you got one too should i get a number
on you
oh yeah what's up babe
[Applause]
get
get there's this and a lot more let me
show you
guys so this comes out tomorrow at 10 am
pst this cool shirt
uh these so this is actually crazy we
have
five one of one custom shirts
that is original by the artist and
they're being sold exclusively as an nft
no
that's a funny idea but no did you get
the actual shirt oh yeah wait it's a
physical item yeah it's a real shirt you
can wear it
you can touch it that crypto [ __ ]
it's a lot cheaper than most nfts too
which is kind of crazy like a lot
cheaper one of one
so those are going up i guess whoever's
fastest gets them
they're really cool man i love these
shirts and then
uh this is one shirt that we're making
so the front says good bears go to
heaven the back says oh they didn't show
it bad bears go everywhere else
but i like it it's a good shirt hail
yeah that's my shirt looking better on
him than me obviously
good bears go to heaven
oh yeah and then also there's like a
there's a bunch of custom tote bags that
are one of one too i don't know how many
they made
there's not that many like i don't know
30 or some [ __ ]
yeah so there you have it guys um cool
yeah it's fun i love it it's nice
yeah it's awesome
we might run some of these ones uh
because i love them so much as like a
mass production but you'll get the
original whoever buys it now
which is obviously pretty sick
and there you have it teddyfrasier.com
okay
thank you i don't know who i just found
this website
i don't know who owns it but it's
looking good
like their work
so um moving on from that
i actually have a segment about dan here
and
this is some top of the show stuff
you've seen these dan i'm sure they
people say you look like everything no
i've never seen any of those yes you
have this is dan
um i see it
do you see it you see it do you see it
i'm sort of marionette oh yeah i mean i
guess so you're not really the marine
yet though you're the puppet master
aren't you these are all from just like
the last like 10 days yeah this is a
constant thing
dan makes christian music
i see it
i see it a little bit
would you ever rock a hat like that dan
i mean so it does something it covers
the whole dome that's nice
if you're insecure about that i'm not
i'm not quaker so
oh you think that's quaker rock that's
quaker quicker oats yeah
i like that oatmeal rock i love
dan is a good man oh wow this swiss
swiss dog from the 15th century looks a
lot like dan
i'm seeing it's good i'm really seeing
it
um
great seeing ethan and dan let loose oh
come on that that's that's out that's
out of pocket yeah no i'm into it
just because of the dome probably huh
just because of the dome
and like i mean look at my hands
relative to yours
your massive like beefy yeah my hands
are looking pretty good that's a pretty
realistic ratio yeah i agree it's good
to view to point out never before seen
picture of dan i mean okay
that's just a rabbit with a beard guys
yeah that's pushing a little bit dan is
ready for the next boxing match what is
this guy looks nothing like dan
what the [ __ ]
you have well you guys have the same
beautiful blue eyes
uh i see down in him you do you too yeah
seriously
he's a little more jacked than me
when this guy has sex these braids must
get in the way he's got it yeah maybe he
ties him
like a knot above his head unless his
partner holds on to them maybe oh
come true handlebars yeah but if he's on
top and you imagine those braids just
slapping you in the face and i hit wet
hair it's like a rain what do you got
what do you ladies think about that
i don't feel good about it yeah no i
don't like it yeah i wouldn't like that
i don't think all right
he probably ties him back though
which isn't really that sexy to think
about either like a hair net made of
hair
but okay
oh now this looks like dan
oh jesus doug clifford from
who wait what band credence klein water
yes
dude he looks like dan zach what the
[ __ ]
does [ __ ] look like what does that
mean i don't know dude it's like dan's
favorite band so like you know oh
absolutely my favorite it's like [ __ ]
dude this dog looks like dan of course
oh well he's a cutie at least there's
that other dog i don't know if it's
included in the black one the one that
people post all the time that's like
[ __ ] terrifying so much like yeah
demon dog
but you know what
oh yeah here it is just one last one
this is this is everyone's favorite the
demon dog that looks like dan why would
you why would you do this to your poor
dog do you love this animal or not
facial structure why does it have a
human ear yeah that's edited that can't
be real that ear doesn't make sense
that must be a version where they they
added on an ear i don't think the
original has that the dogs don't have
human ears
that's like dolly dan
dolly dan
you know salvador dali
a little disturbing and
yeah i was skeptical at first but i feel
like these all kind of look like dan
holy [ __ ]
wait there's more
what the [ __ ]
what the i've never seen this one
what's with the ear dude no what the
[ __ ]
sorry the dome i get but why does it
have ears that's just not right
you know somebody said he thinks cam
says it's a snapchat filter he thinks oh
well dan i i i think it totally looks
like you man no it does it does really
does yeah yeah fair enough at least its
eyes aren't glowing like a [ __ ]
hellhound in that one
you mean this one
the original yeah
okay that looks like you
this one i really see it
that's dan man
anyway
anyway we're celebrating dan um
we are
happy to celebrate dan
and um
yeah i i think we all see
we all see the resemblance to dan yeah i
think all of us
yeah do you do you see it dan for real
mm-hmm yeah yeah do you see yourself
everywhere you go or it's it's
everywhere i look i just can't sometimes
i look in the mirror and i see dan yeah
weird me too yeah weirdly
especially today dan is all
were you guys wearing this earlier
no i just dressed like this yeah i just
this was my fit
actually let me take this i wear this
like every day just laid this out last
night
actually it's dan's fit five year
anniversary we're celebrating been here
for five long years five [ __ ] years
that's pretty incredible kidding me and
of course
we are all
we see a little dan in all of us wait
something feels a little wait will you
hold on will you guys take your beanies
off oh yeah it feels off here yeah a
little warm
oh my god
oh what happened guys dude what
we did the
we
we did the uh
condom on your head challenge
oh no
oh i think i know what this means guys
the transformation is happening
oh [ __ ] this happened not the
transformation once every thousand years
no i think we have to make our way to
the dan chamber
not the damn chamber
everyone up everyone up the dan chamber
yes no
could it be the bathroom that you all
were hovering around all morning today
no no no okay come on join us dan okay
dan's going to sit right here right
yeah get him
[Music]
this is the chamber of den
behold i guess i should take this off
since we're all doing the bald thing
right now
behold the chamber of den
today we give honor and praise
to the great dan swordlove the wizard
he hath given us so much of himself over
these five years
he has given off
so much
and asked for so little
today we celebrate
and potentially give kobe 2
dance word love
would everyone like to share a word of
their favorite dance name
hunger
hunger
hunger
hunger hunger fungi hunger
[Applause]
dan
in honor of your five years of faithful
servitude you get coveted
we present to you
this five year oh
letterman jacket a letterman windbreaker
wow
oh look
bedazzled on the back
what an honor
and inside um
inside there's a little something
special there for you as well
and it's not and i'll say it's not a
gift card to sharky's
even better i kind of figured
[Music]
hunger bunger
bungalow
stop you're firing
nice
me
think of your order tickets
oh
box seats front row baby let's go
jamie xx
i'm a fan yeah for sure and and caribou
do you like caribou oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
they're opening yes oh that's [ __ ]
legit
thank you
i give you a hug but i'm a little afraid
too right now wait do we know what row
they're in
it says garden box one yep that's it
baby
put two funkles up japan
five years of greatness five years of
excellence wow
five fingers up for dan actually yeah
five fingers put five fingers in the air
if you wanted
and then i was i was like right i was
like wait what's a five finger salute
oh [ __ ] no not that one
i was just wondering what's a five
finger salute yeah i have the sound bite
but i promised dana wouldn't play it
anymore play it what is that high old
hitler
oh my god
stop the five finger salute
wow
you know what else is a five finger
salute
just a normal salute you didn't actually
oh yeah
the thumb's not pointing though that's
why your hand is still has five bangs
you guys think this counts as a five
finger i'm just saying you didn't really
i was like well i want to put my five
fingers out to you and then we'll just
keep them open why do they open it it's
not bad just keep them open yeah like
this spread
i just don't know why they get this it's
like
it's like a salute you put your hand out
why do they get that
yeah that's why we need you dan you
bring balance to the force
five long gears
everybody
give it up to dance word
five fingers for damn
well thank you thank you i'm honored i
love the jacket
that [ __ ] bro i i figured the the
bedazzling kind of gave it away she made
the whole damn thing though really the
dazzling
the baby i only know one person who
bedazzles so
like at all
i know one person
well there you have it
everyone's putting five fingers in the
air for dan i see that thank you thank
you everyone in the chat for your kind
words
by the way
can you get a shot of
i don't me
if you can tell you look [ __ ] scary
it looks just look like you had a condom
stretched over your head you can't tell
how wet my head is the wellbutrin makes
me sweat like a [ __ ] pig i had to
lower my dosage this morning because i
can't do it anymore i can't do it the
sweating is insane and i'm not a sweaty
person
i'm not look at this look at this
look at this i don't know if you can see
jesus
yeah no
no no it's [ __ ] it's like freak [ __ ]
it's well i mean those caps look like
you sweat look at all the look look how
wet i am oh my god no i never swinging
you're flinging covet virus off your
head
can you sweat kovid i don't know
thank you
i don't know
so probably not it's disgusting theodore
goes
he goes i like non-sweaty daddy better
no way yeah he said that to me
i said i taking this new medicine that
makes me sweat he goes i like
non-sweating daddy better
said me too buddy
me too
so i'm lowering my dosage in the hope
that that helps
because it's not a weight there's no way
to live god damn it
well there you go dan
thank you again thank you again
it's an honor to be a part of the show
and uh here's to five more hopefully we
won't get
banned from youtube
by that but
for another five
just
just saying within the next five years
that i'm sure we'll get decent chances
right but i don't know about band
we're good
i hope not as long as we have you we'll
be okay
yeah as long as you're here we'll
survive
does anyone want this um sweat rack
it's pretty wet oh i'm good i'm good i
bet i could drip water off it not even
kidding i bet you i could produce a drip
of water nobody's
taking that bet
okay
there you go
all right so we got a show to do here
what else we got
okay so speaking of covid stuff
these guys keep it classy
the quartering and keemstar were both
making fun of me for having coveted i
don't think i would ever stoop that low
do you i don't think so
look at this one dude
this shit's nuts bro
dude straight up did simpson celebrating
gif
i said i tested positive for colvin and
this [ __ ] goes
we're ready i'll celebrate what dumb
of course it doesn't upset me but i'm
just like
i i can't believe that someone would be
well people are they'll say that because
we
have uh talked at length about people
dying of cohen
uh
didn't celebrate anyone dying yeah not
really celebrate but like you know we
did like that herman cain award thing
but i mean i think more ironic destiny
it's like right exactly darwin award
death yes that's right it's really
herman cain awards is really just a
darwin awards that's it right
you know
but just straight up no context just
simpsons yay
oh here i guess they're all cheering and
bart is sad
yeah [ __ ] awesome bro shout out
quartering legend to the end
um poor
i ta oh and then he is funny he's
responding
uh to the same tweet he said thank
goodness you were vaccinated and double
boosted i don't know
how many [ __ ] times it needs to be
explained to you
why do you still pretend like you don't
understand how this works
it lowers the severity bro you know if i
wasn't vaccinated double boosted i'd be
really scared sure when i was sick you
know i'd be like [ __ ] dude there's like
a chance i'm gonna die from this but i
didn't have those thoughts because i
knew i was vaccinated and double boosted
and it's pretty incredible that even now
you still don't understand that you're
that willfully ignorant
or just outright dumb that you would
actually think that was a good thing to
tweet i'm [ __ ] my pants it's pretty
incredible take
um
and then i i i guess maybe he felt bad
after
celebrating me being sick
uh-oh
and really my wife and child being sick
too
all you don't even have to think about
it memes aside i hope you feel better no
joke covet sucks well thank you but
still [ __ ] you
idiot dumbass also spreading kovac miss
info you dumb [ __ ] office [ __ ]
[ __ ] claw machine operating freak
hey dude
hey dude don't ask for my son's address
to send him candy and prizes i'm not
giving it to you
you know like on this claw machine
channel yeah thank you right
you're going to have some bad apples in
that bunch yeah no kidding bro
keemstar of course coming out
i love that they all have to comment on
it you know
one like equal one prayer
uh he posted uh have you scrolled down
there bigger images yeah okay i tested
positive blah blah blah
and then keemstar tweeted out this other
article coronavirus attacks fat tissue
scientists find i thought this one was
pretty funny actually
i didn't have a problem with this one
terrorist
terrorist terrorist
you know he's just calling me fat and
that's fine
i get it
keemstar was like fat as [ __ ] like five
months ago though
and now all of a sudden he like hates
fat people isn't that funny
um
what is this h3h3 fans trying to get my
youtube band
because i prayed for his speedy recovery
sure keem slide baby
uh-huh yeah why even like post it it's
like your fans don't believe that you
don't believe that nobody reading it
believes it
it's just
like who is that for
i think it's like it's it's like
no i don't think keemstar is a white
nationalist but they they do that same
[ __ ] where they go like uh
it's like plausible deniability and
you're giving a wink to all the other
people you know it's like the insider
thing i guess
i don't i'm not saying he is a white
nationalist
although he i wouldn't be surprised if
he was what does he have to say about it
zach
game star keepsaker
[Music]
death to all jews oh
that's that's really on the nose yeah do
you think i hate jewish people i want to
know
okay that's three separate sound bites
now
starting to recognize a pattern here so
i hate the jews four
different sound bites now
there's there's clearly something going
millions of jews
six different sound bites one for every
millions of jews that died
then you got him talking about uh i'm
basically hitler oh right right and now
i'm hitler oh my god so what is that
it's really stacking up dude seven eight
but anyway this one per this round one
person goes
hi youtube drum alert channel uh host
keemstar just posted this poll to see
how many people would wish another one
of the creators severely ill
there was no pull right
i think they just meant the yeah i think
the one like one prayer yes exactly
they're just being straight up nasty as
a premium member i hope you
you need to keep coming but i can't read
but
whatever it's just some zero like post
and then he's like
this h3 fans are trying to ruin my
[ __ ] life bro
most evil fan base how did he yeah how
did he even find that he's reading his
replies which is kind of psycho to begin
with 63 replies he reads them all
fair enough
oh god he's still going death to all
jews was a meme from pewdiepie everyone
at the time understood this
yo
dude hell nah
nice try rewriting history what happened
to i he didn't first of all he goes i
never said that and then
he goes dude let's remember the context
you told while you were live streaming
all your followers to go to ethan klein
on twitter and tell him death to all
jesus after [ __ ] talking to you for
about a good half hour yeah that's not a
[ __ ] pewdiepie
holy [ __ ] the fact that ethan klein and
his fans keep taking this out of context
is disgusting oh shut up you dumb [ __ ]
yeah last year we had future technology
to make up the sound bite were those
are those recent tweets
is he like still talking yeah this is
just this is from this mo or june you
know it's kind of crazy because like
i read this his original tweet and i was
like that's funny you know
i'm not even mad but then he's got to
keep going and all this crazy ass [ __ ]
oh i see i didn't even know he did this
about the jordan peterson one
whatever who gives a [ __ ] disgusting
oh my god he's even jumping on the the
uh
exercises
life's too short to exercise i'm just
gonna be honest life's too short he
tweeted this out it's like a two to one
not even one second long disgusting bro
you're so desperate what the [ __ ] that's
just stupid fitness guru yeah keemstar
disgusting
he just saw that there's lots of people
sharing this clip so he's like oh [ __ ]
there must be something here
actually you know funny enough
i don't know if you guys know who this
guy greek god x is but he got i
i was in my basement diana covid and
this guy starts tweeting me out of
nowhere can you find that a.b
he's used to be a twitch
streamer or he got uh he just got banned
like
last week or something for hit that
crazy misogynistic rant which we should
watch that too
but he used to be friends with i don't
know a bunch of i don't
know i don't know anything about the guy
except that he lost he's known as a
legend i don't know he's gone off the
deep end
completely on the
past half year super weird
so you see my campaign against exercise
might be onto something
because if this is your brain on
exercise
then i think we all need to lay the [ __ ]
off sorry ethan you said he tweeted at
you
he tagged me
and i responded so it should just be in
my feed
[Music]
but i love this clip of the um
the exercise gag that somehow has turned
into a thing
so i was just in my basement dying a
covered
and this [ __ ] starts tweeting at
me
that i'm a disgusting vile piece of [ __ ]
because i joked that
exercise is a waste of time
oh my god
i just peed in my basement
let's see
yeah so this is why kim starts putting
out this clip very weird he goes he tags
me too right he's looking for the smoke
he says when ashrae said this i lost all
respect for him just kidding i never had
any respect for him in the first place
what a bad example for humanity
life's too short to exercise i'm just
gonna be honest there's so many better
things to do than exercise we have why
does this trigger on earth
like this is it's kind of surprising to
me you can hear people laughing it's
it's very clear that you're joking but
even if you're not it's like it's not
why are you so insecure that
this is like so upset it's like if you
enjoy exercising great you're not trying
to ban jim yeah i'm just giving an
opinion but i think people are so
desperate to try to [ __ ]
get me on anything i mean keemstar put
this out like bro you're a fat [ __ ] bro
you eat syrup and with a fork you freak
like [ __ ] we don't remember what the
[ __ ] you do shut up about exercise
yeah running in the force for a dollar
okay [ __ ]
i'm only running you down is well he did
lose a lot of weight but i'm just saying
shut up
lipo yeah
lightbulb you think that's a good rumor
to start
i mean i'm not basing that on anything
other than he doesn't seem like the type
that would be motivated to actually put
in the work to lose that much weight and
it happened really fast
okay brother got a lipo there's some
evidence to support that den
there's busted
anyway i uh responded
and of course he didn't he didn't want
any smoke but i'm sitting here minding
my own [ __ ] basement diana covett and
this [ __ ] goon
and starts tweeting at me
what a bad example for humanity so wait
let me see what i've said
by the way just shout out to all the
mass shootings on july 4th
shout out it's awesome huh
it's awesome [ __ ] oh here i said it's
called a joke you silly [ __ ] dude
what the [ __ ] are we doing
this isn't even like an offensive joke
i said also didn't you just get banned
from twitch for saying essentially that
women are slaves well get the [ __ ] out
weirdo dark ass loser
here's the clip by the way that just
he just got banned for
so get a load of this [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] greek god x what a loser dude
he's literally and by the way he's a fit
this guy's an actual fan
of cobra tay like i went on his feed i
was like this is some cobra tate [ __ ]
straight up cobra tate memes on his feed
right now
watch this
and this goes to any women women who
want to date me especially female
streamers that want to date me okay
if you want to date me you better
believe i will be the even if you're
streaming you're gonna have to stop
streaming streaming is ended for you
your career is done okay i will stream
while you cook for me and you clean for
me and you look after the children well
i gain all the money and i give it to
you and i give it to our children for a
healthy secure life okay that's how i
want to run my life
okay that's my life that i want to do it
now it's up to you and other people in
their other worlds whatever they want to
do but my reality i'm going to sit here
earn all the money you're going to be in
the kitchen cooking why are you already
angry at your hypothetical wife that
doesn't even exist if you lose her ass
dork [ __ ] loser [ __ ]
she's like i'm already pissed at you
you're already doing everything yeah
yeah what a loser bro what a catch this
guy is though right i mean yeah yeah the
ladies his dms must be packed yeah dude
this is awesome after this to all of the
women lining up to date me okay
you do nothing you quit your job i give
you money i own you
i'm cleaning and making sure my home is
[ __ ] clean and i'm gonna make sure we
have money so we can have a home and you
have a place to sleep at night okay but
is it called work bro are you caveman
having a place to sleep at night like
what is this [ __ ]
people looking for shelter
it's not we're not in the apocalypse yet
dude we're not shelter is not that big
of a [ __ ] deal for most people
we most of us have shelter bro it's not
that good of a proposition
working together
okay
all right okay because streaming i
believe it or not is mentally damaging
to my mind oh [ __ ] oh what oh [ __ ]
oh so love what do you make of this
because you said this guy used to be a
legend
i want to make it very clear because i
said this on twitter too people got
butthurt over me i wasn't defending him
i was just saying in the past i mean
he's been a really good streamer and
like an iconic streamer and everything
uh but lately i don't know what the hell
happened uh
he's known for losing like a bunch of
weight he used to be like giant
and he lost a lot of weight and uh
lately when he went back to his country
from america everyone
or he just lost touch with everything
and he got he's like mean to his friends
he's streaming friends and no one knows
why
i feel like he's he's obviously
i think he's on steroids first of all
because my gut reaction is that
something is not right i know i
shouldn't like delve into anything too
deep but something isn't right i'm
almost like a little bit worried that
something has happened or going to
happen or anything like that
i um oh yeah i think like look at this
all of his tweets are pretty crazy
paying to see girl naked equal beta cuck
who will never find real love it's all
like
alpha [ __ ] so many overweight beta males
who talk [ __ ] on twitter no matter what
you do no one wants to breed with you go
to the gym bro nobody is reading reading
does he have kids this [ __ ]
named breeding does he have kids hell no
what the [ __ ] are you talking about dude
sex
that's pretty [ __ ] beta you don't
even have any kids by the way you don't
even have a girlfriend oh yeah he liked
this or retweeted it or something
i see no difference
cobra tate
by the way i see a difference overtake
has money
and your ass doesn't but also he's a sex
trafficker right and so i'm not sure
that that's someone to look you know
i just want to point out that he claims
that the reason he got banned was for
something else he said he was twerking
on stream
that was the final straw yeah because
he's been abandoned the past couple
other times whatever i don't care what
he got banned for the video speaks for
itself right you know he's unbound by
the way
but i found it interesting he didn't
respond to me because he tagged me
and he wanted the heat and so i gave it
to him and then he bitched out yeah i
mean that's [ __ ] that's baited [ __ ] he
bitched out he said yo tag ethan talk
some [ __ ] and then when ethan comes over
the top and dunks on you like the beta
[ __ ] you are i just to you dude i just
cucked you dear mom bro i just [ __ ]
your mom and you watched and cried bro
because that's what betas do i i sucked
all the testosterone out of your [ __ ]
tits bro like a like a starving calf and
you were left no testosterone [ __ ]
crawling on the floor like a withered
old [ __ ] raisin
and you didn't even respond to me dude
what's up with that you're such a little
[ __ ] that's beta [ __ ] man
you have no testosterone i'm talking
about he's talking about
you know
the woman of his dreams that he doesn't
have
he's talking about you know beta cooks
and breeding he doesn't have any kids
you know he talks about how alpha he is
but he
needs
his wife to cook and like clean for you
like aren't you successful like hire
some help at the house like you need you
need a wife to cook for you
you have enough money to pay for a maid
what are you doing dude
pathetic
well he's also not drinking his bubble
water bubble water are you drinking your
bubble wrap flat water you [ __ ] idiot
bubble water well cobra tate said it who
[ __ ] cooks get a [ __ ] five dollar
chicken from costco
and eat that [ __ ] down you loser [ __ ]
yeah
beta behavior this guy goes holy [ __ ] so
many twitch streamers leeching off my
success low bro at this point i'm gonna
need to give out
i'm gonna go live to give them clips to
watch um
how many people are watching him right
now
i think they were all reacting to that
clip oh you're asking currently
yeah i mean probably around 10k
okay
he's a big streamer very very big
really
because i have 40 000. what does that
mean
it means he's a beta and he's [ __ ]
sucking my nuts right now definitely
he's not live right now
you didn't respond man
what's with that
[Music]
you know
here he is colbert this is just july 1st
this just happened
so
oh and then he got all religious too
which is always a bad sign
with peace and love to our christians
but you know how i feel about that you
just your brain goes to rot and too much
jesus
now this is
okay
yo he got jesus that's crazy bro i don't
know if that was a joke or not because
someone folks showed the bible there
with his logo
he goes it's actually sad to see so many
girls sell their bodies for money
there's more to life than that
like being my domestic servant
that's true yeah what do you mean
there's more to life than that your life
sounds your your dream life for your
wife sounds way worse why wouldn't they
want to be independently wealthy and
actually want to then they can go hook
up with someone they actually like
they get to pick the guys that they like
and of course he's a trump fan trump was
a way better president i'm so confused
on why anyone would vote sleepy joe
trump is a walking w
so there you have it greek god x you're
a [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] you coward away
from me you cowered away from me when
you tweeted at me
that's how i feel about that i'm gonna
keep [ __ ] your mouth bro like
like uh chris rock
case closed
greek got x
hell no
anyway thanks for watching guys we're
here we're out here it's off the rails
july 6th also i might forgot to mention
not only have the worst birthday ever
i caught covert on my birthday i had the
worst july 4th ever
was horrible i've done nothing to
celebrate my birthday i turned 37 not 40
by the way before you guys can say
i would it say that i just wanted to say
that
so there was that
[Music]
hey we had a really good um
falling off the stage update
connoisseurs of performers falling off
the stage there was a really good one
that dropped
cardi playboy cardi
what's he do you guys fans of the
playboy
he has a few good songs yeah
he was on connie's recent album too
he was that guy that um
on the stream in florida he was like
just screaming into the mic with all the
face paint on
you remember that
um but i will say this tweet has 300 000
likes and 11 million views so
let's see it guys let's enjoy this
dude just
whoa
that's a glory day dude
yeah i'm so interested in this i mean it
seems to happen so often where these
performers just
yeah
totally
that's a pretty good one though don't
you think yeah that's solid yeah i
wonder if he got hurt it didn't look
like it there's another angle where he
you see that he just gets right he pops
up so we were at another angle we were
debating this i felt like the recovery
was pretty flawless considering dude it
looked he fell off the stage very
gracefully now i haven't seen this right
so the recovery is pretty
it's pretty good let's see
jesus work on your camera work okay dude
he's fine yeah like that was a great
recovery right totally he meant to do
that [ __ ]
like boom it's like he's jerk dancing
you know
he's getting up but i'll tell you what
you fall off a stage backwards that's
like a five foot drop that's terrifying
i would definitely break my ankle or
some [ __ ] no he he's a straight-up
i'm in legend okay shout out playboy
cardi following gracefully
that's of course kelsey grammer
one of my favorite
one of the best yeah one of the best
so that's an exciting update
um
what else we got is for how was
everyone's fourth of july you guys do
anything fun
anybody it was fun yeah i hang out with
alex ernst just family get together it
was nice
quiet you guys are like best friends now
what's going on with that we we we
trauma bonded over the crater clash
we we didn't get a trauma he beat the
[ __ ] out of that no i mean like prior to
the fight we talked oh yeah
yeah you guys are homies yeah
so you got invited to the family cookout
yeah
and it was just his family it was his
girlfriend's family very sweet people
you went to his girlfriend's family
that's like a that's like a huge invite
bro that's like real friendship we're in
there
what the hell
are you guys best friends now
we're buds
i mean we i we don't have a lot of
friends out here besides the crew so
was it a pity invite
no
i don't i hope not
alex really likes a.b
during the whole lead up to the boxing
match uh he was reaching out to abe all
the time
you know but an invite to this
girlfriend's i agree that's pretty
personal that is personal and you there
was no other it wasn't like a gathering
right no i was the only i was only pale
there okay well that's personal bro
did you did you ever be like yo we don't
have plans for fourth we don't know what
to do no i definitely didn't
did you bring something
i did
what'd you bring potluck uh so we
brought we didn't know what to bring so
we just brought a bunch of alcohol
because we don't
we don't know what standard so what kind
of boost did you bring
i don't even know everything we got i
know they like wine we got some random
wine okay
you guys turn up no just no you guys
don't drink ever right you keep goody
goody yeah he's trying to be good guys
it's interesting you guys brought
alcohol and you don't drink
it happens that's very interesting but
okay and how was the food you guys do a
little cookouts and burgers and dogs
yeah
yeah
did they like [ __ ] on fire
no fireworks no not responsible
yeah um
a b everybody maybe moving up he's in
with the vlog squad
i wonder he's in i wouldn't say i think
it's more that we're stealing alex from
well i i you know i followed alex
because i i found like he is friends
with ab and maybe he's warming up to us
and he's like the he's like not
problematic at all member of the vlog
squad but he doesn't follow me he just
likes a b he does he does follow anyone
not he only falls oh he doesn't fall out
yeah okay
i was offended
i took it personally
no he's really nice
do you think he wants to be friends with
any of us other of us or just you he i
think he just wants to be friends with
everyone he thinks he doesn't want to be
involved ethan's kind of in the market
for a best friend after yeah with jeff
that's so yeah things fell through i'm
looking for a new are you feeling a
little jealous i'm i'm just i'm i'm a
little no it makes sense i'm prying a
little bit here well you we we're
working on mike now right we're we're
working very hard to find your new best
well what what were you doing zach
on the fourth yeah we went to uh
chantal's family and so you wouldn't
even invite his ass to chantal and you
guys are like besties but yet alex is
inviting abe
to his girlfriend's
did you see what i'm saying it's it's
our intimacy level is crazy but maybe
they're closer than we think i don't
know maybe this is the first time you
met it must be alex is a girlfriend
no i've been in their house before
have you slept over there let's just go
get a sleepover no we play guitar hero
but i didn't sleep over okay just
curious guitar hero is pretty mega
bonding wow
interesting
well we love alex don't we
shout out alex
trying to
move in kind of fast so one of my guys
maybe need to slow the face a little bit
he didn't ask me permission
you know
is there someone yeah it's that mean
yeah i consented i consented that
someone you forgot to ask next hangout
ab you got invited ethan that's that's
how it's gonna be from now on
yeah or at least ask for permission
i'll facetime you when i'm there
that would be nice to be checking on
yeah
i'm just looking after you i say take
care of my boy
man hmm
somebody said greek god l i like that
giant [ __ ] loser wow
dunked
lena did you have fun at uh over there
yeah yeah i did yeah and they were so
sweet both of them alex and his
girlfriend
wow
must be nice must be nice yeah it was
really nice
yeah it's awesome
did they was there halal food for you
guys or you don't need halal do you i
don't know i just don't eat pork but
yeah
they have like ribs or yeah
next time i'll take a bunch of photos
i'll document it i'll vlog it you don't
remember what you ate come on
alex be the chicken buffalo dipper what
kind of it was delicious
just a buffalo dip what kind of barbecue
sauce is that family are they like kind
of sweet baby raisins uh
they do rocking something else yeah i
think they're sweet baby rays was it
sweet baby raisins sweet baby raises
their game so did they have like they
had a buffalo dip what else yeah what
was the main course the dip's not a main
course it's just the apps on the fourth
did you have a hamburger yeah hamburger
beef what kind of seasoning
yeah why are you being shy what kind of
was the burger not good was it dry
do you don't want it all right you don't
want to offend alex you guys are joking
i'm serious what kind of seasoning they
use larry's on that burger or was it
like a dinos like
all right all right all right all right
all right they're lovely people it was
a.i they grill better than us
don't say that that can't be true i
grill like a monster this guy is the
grill king don't say that
is he good he's getting quiet let me ask
you this he got really quiet
did alex grill did alex grill or was it
her dad or what
i'd rather not comment on that what what
i'm kidding
by the time i got there the food was
done okay all right all right still like
did you talk to the dad zach what did
you do did you talk shawn
did you yes i did but that was like
that's my oh
that's a good that's a good throwback
that's a good throwback i got i got rip
[ __ ] dude i got pretty uh pretty twisty
nice choice anna all right all right
um
was jeff's dad there though or was it
just his girlfriend's dad his name is
alex not jeff
but oddly enough jeff wittig's dad was
there jeff with it
wait was alex dad there were they off
doing their own thing no no alex's
family lives out of state oh they live
out of state okay wait but i thought you
went to the family house it's his
girlfriend
you know thank god we are actually close
because this would be super [ __ ]
weird why if we weren't
you know these are standard questions
about that
these are conversations that happen off
camera what was their bathroom like
this is nice did they have the kirkland
two-ply or
you know or the or the good shoe let me
ask you this
you guys were probably in the backyard
right
and there's a point where you need to go
the bathroom so you asked one of them
can i go to the bathroom and then did
they lead you in like some kind of weird
maze through their house to get to the
bathroom tell me about the experience or
was it just like uh
second door on the left well i i've been
there before oh okay what you've been to
his girlfriend's house before oh they
had lena
because that was my first time there and
yeah i had to use the restroom and they
just told me where to go they didn't
have to walk me there they went like
second what'd they say like you know
second
door on the left or whatever one of
those like what's the like what's the
layout of the house like
like what's the address
did they have
hold on did they have decorative soaps
lina
decorative yeah they're like they're
soaps that look cute but you're not
supposed to use it in the shape of it i
don't recall it nothing stood out i have
a question it just looked like it was a
bar soap or was it pumped i have a
question did they have a communal towel
probably okay
communal towel it's a big it's a good
call let me ask you this
let me ask you this when you dried your
hands was the towel wet or dry
there was a guy in a tuxedo in the
bathroom
we're being serious right now
and he dried my hands
with the communal towel yeah and i felt
bad i didn't have any change to tip him
lena uh do you recall the damn this one
i know
i wasn't expecting i don't know
there was nothing weird that stood out
to me okay it's like i was using my own
bathroom did you sneak into any rooms
i did not all right all right all right
enough
there's central air or is it like a
window unit no no no no come on
we don't want to pry into their privacy
in their private
food
inappropriate
wait i have and actually
i have a legit question that is
important when it comes to a grill is it
charcoal or gas i the food was made by
the time i got there so you know
you know what i mean did you taste it
you can taste it you could taste the
charcoal
bro was it charcoal or gas you need to
answer
i don't i'm not sure lena do you know if
it was dry
no because i didn't have the hamburgers
or hot dogs oh okay okay did you get it
did they spray pam on the grill before
they started all right guys come on this
is too much just stop stop stop
saw how many people were there
approximately
i'm just kidding i'll let go let it go
but that's nice that's nice you had a
good that's cool
that's really cool man yeah it's awesome
i'm happy for you thank you yeah i
didn't do anything yeah i got a friend i
didn't do anything maybe didn't do
anything yeah i didn't do anything i
thought
uh yeah were you trying to get an invite
dan
i don't know i just i didn't do anything
on the fourth so
it would have been where was where was
my invite to the soccer game last week
yeah i did invite you i invited
everybody in the office if i did i
didn't get invited well
you wouldn't have gone yeah you're right
yeah i know i'm just like i'm just
kidding i know you well enough yeah yeah
i'm just kidding in fact i did you a
favor by not asking and putting in a
position 100 yeah no you're total you're
100 right all right let's move on thank
you everybody i'm glad everyone had a
happy fourth
we actually have a little segment here
about the fourth
firework disasters do you think i'm
gonna get in trouble for showing any of
this are we gonna get busted like well
philly
showed the first one so
you think that i show speed one is fine
i mean
so it's not age restricted
uh which is surprising because that is
it's an amazing clip
i'd like to show it but if you want to
play it safe it might be best to just
skip
yeah i know youtube they they get all
crazy about dangerous acts this guy lit
a
firework in his room this is the
firework if you want to show it well
i'll show i'll show like a still of it
maybe
i mean here
and
what really like i guess it's funny
whatever
he it was all live so i was like oh
awesome you know epic
but really sucks is that the fire
department had to come
yeah check it out and that really
actually is really [ __ ] lame look at
this
because
obviously
that's a big day for them and i'm sure
there's more important things to be
doing
but uh that happened that was a pretty
viral thing did he get in trouble for
that i was thinking youtube might
i was imagining he would get a
strike definitely
at least for dangerous acts or whatever
yeah i didn't hear anything yet i was
looking for that specifically i didn't
not confirmed
oh so this is the pikachu firework he
went off in his room yeah okay it looks
so small in this all right it gets more
intense but i mean in a small room yeah
on a bed yeah
that's what the fireworks
that's a lot in a tiny room with sheets
and everywhere
yo where do you get pokemon fireworks
this kind of
fire's gonna come out that butthole yeah
baby happen fourth of july
nothing is on fire i repeat nothing is
on fire yeah man we used to have the
best fourth of july players when i was a
kid
we'd throw bangers bro and get like mad
fireworks from ojai
hmm
so dub in ojai we had the other drive
hella far to get fireworks because they
were illegal in ventura county
what the hell why would they say ohi
though that's like wildfire central it's
like the worst place well i don't know
that they're they you just once you
enter
the city yeah there's just stalls of
fireworks sellers on the side of the
street and everybody from ventura county
and around where it's illegal goes there
and buys the fireworks and then comes
back the one i went to when i was out
there was called phantom fireworks
but they used to sell on the side of the
road though
yeah i don't know the name they're all
just generic looking as [ __ ] there's a
bunch of phantom fireworks in michigan
man they had a crazy selection of [ __ ]
though
but anyway i hope everyone had a good
fourth of july
wasn't much to celebrate my opinion
considering there was
two mass shootings
on fourth of july that was why because i
i had an invite to go to a backyard
barbecue party or whatever
i thought about it i was just like
kind of
kind of [ __ ] america right now i don't
know i don't really feel what are we
celebrating
why am i gonna go [ __ ] act like
everything's okay right now dude america
was a mistake that's what the world so
i just decided to take it easy
yeah so there are you guys i'm sure you
all saw or heard there was a horrific
mass shooting in a small town
by a maggot a mega kid 22 years old
pretty sure it was a ar
it sounded like it in the video
um
killed five people
injured like dozens
one of the most the saddest anecdotes i
heard from that
there was a little girl found wandering
the streets by herself
all traumatized and they're like where's
your parents well they found out both of
her parents were killed
jesus right in front of her
at a fourth of july celebration that
they took their two-year-old daughter to
go celebrate i believe it was a boy
named
yeah but it was horrible
um yikes
that is horrific to think about
and that's that's kind of just that's
the world we live in i mean it's not the
world we live that's the country we live
in where that stuff is a weekly
occurrence um
and and and nothing happens it's it's
truly utterly [ __ ]
pathetic
and then there was another shooting in
philadelphia hoards of people running
for their lives and this is it this this
is america
fourth of july everyone's celebrating
and there's just mass shootings dude
people running for their lives kids
parents being murdered and we just move
on like [ __ ] nothing happened it's
disgusting dude it's nauseating
unfucking fathomably
i mean it's cancer dude we're living
with cancer and we refuse to to do
anything do anything about it
we're basically doing like
we're basically dying of like a curable
cancer and doing like homeopathic
remedies for it
that's what we're doing right steve jobs
we're drinking juice we're doing a juice
cleanse for our cancer
um
there was more than a dozen mass
shootings in the us over fourth of july
weekend
lovely that's crazy
that's [ __ ] nuts i'm not even feeling
safe to go to public gatherings anymore
i'll be totally honest
i mean
realistically
i think statistically i don't give a
[ __ ] well not really that risky but i
understand i don't give a [ __ ] dude you
go to a public gathering fourth of july
yo
so someone's gonna come shoot it up
there's a chance [ __ ] that yeah this
country's not safe anymore
it's like
it's like terrorism on our own people
nobody wants to do [ __ ] isn't that crazy
dude we're just doing a juice [ __ ]
cleanse with cancer
it's crazy man
it's so sad
yeah
it's hard it's hard to even i don't know
what to say about it anymore
you know
really is just so [ __ ] up
um
let's see
alec baldwin
and [ __ ] woody allen oh you we got an
edit of whatever went down with them
yeah yeah awesome i sat through the
whole hour
oh did you really
so give me basically before i watch the
clips
i'm not going to get into this
depressing gun [ __ ] anymore i've done it
enough there's just you know what i'm
saying nothing [ __ ] matters anymore
bro i'm just becoming a nihilist you
know what i mean what what option do we
have i'm just going to talk about
something fun
so what was your uh impression of that
hour-long conversation
uh they should have had some tech people
standing by oh really it was god-awful
yeah you'll see them and it's really
cool yeah it's really funny that's
what's done interesting yeah it was
about
woody's new book basically
and uh alec kind of fanboying over him
the whole time
it's kind of funny that alec baldwin put
basically put his career on the line for
an interview that did like was so
technically [ __ ] like he didn't even
get an interview out of it yeah what a
loser
[Laughter]
what an idiot bro what a stupid [ __ ]
thing to do alec baldwin
holy [ __ ] yeah he sucks i'm boycotting
alec after that
well i think
the whole industry is probably
boycotting him to be honest holy [ __ ]
dude alec baldwin interviewing woody
allen here we go the best of
this is what he ruined his whole life
career and legacy over guys let's watch
i'm now live
i'm going to take the comments i'm going
to
disable the comments turning on yeah
that's a good idea right off the bat
that's step one there alec
smart
minting i love his golf visor
[Music]
how old is woody that's what i was about
to ask uh
probably
i'm gonna guess don't nobody say it yet
i'm gonna guess
he is
91 years old hell no that old close
whoa
dude he was writing for the
uh what was that show sid caesar show or
whatever in like the late 50s or
something that dude's been around
forever i guess [ __ ] kids makes you
youthful man
that's the secret people have been
saying that for years i sent a picture
of him when he's younger if you want to
look at that
if you just
want to get an idea he look he was
already old
yo this is the this is his stepdaughter
he married huh yeah yo this guy's so
[ __ ] up bro this guy [ __ ] and
married this girl his stepdaughter you
guys do you need anymore and this man is
sick in the [ __ ] head bro that this
relationship is evidence enough that
everything they said is true
and look he's already old this
[ __ ] is old
30 years ago that's what i was saying
like his career started in like i would
say the early 60s or late 50s so wait
how old is he actually 86 so i was
relatively close
but he came out old you know what i mean
he came out
i mean it's true when he was starring in
his movies in like the late 60s and
early 70s he already looked old as [ __ ]
i think he was he's kind of got larry
david syndrome you know
how larry like if you see larry david in
the 80s it was like he was already he
looks we're thinking about larry david
he looks better right well he has money
now so it's probably helps that's true
money helps money's good for that didn't
help me but help some people
all right let's watch this [ __ ]
you can hear me okay woody say something
can you hear him yeah uh yeah yeah
holy [ __ ] you're gonna have to turn it
up
my hearing aids are
gonna get a little loud
not sure what instagram is you should
back the camera off a little bit the
camera's too close
are you trying to direct me out let's
try this just slide it back a bit so
it's more of a bust
are you watching are we live yes you are
we're live okay we're live so we'll just
we'll just ask you don't know you're
live
this is boomer [ __ ] town yeah this
isn't even boomer town this
motherfucker's not even a boomer
it gets better he's the pedo generation
when he was at that age people just be
[ __ ] 15 year olds
that was the name of his
generation i have a facebook page but i
don't know how to i've never seen it i
would know how to access it and i don't
know what it does exactly if you really
love something and you do it with
sincerity
there's a chance that uh you can commute
it's so perfect look at how alec is like
you broke up there
[Laughter]
no [ __ ] buddy
you broke up we lost you again i don't
this is
this is hilarious i don't still don't
understand how people have such bad
reception in this day and age i mean the
internet is so prevalent it's so strong
you're both in your houses presumably
that have high-speed internet yeah
instagram live i mean what the [ __ ]
but yeah that was powerful let me go
back a little bit he was finally going
to make a point yeah do it with
sincerity
there's a chance that uh you can commute
this is what you gave it all up for alec
it's me
this is what you this is what you sold
whatever integrity you had left for my
friend
we lost you
yes we did
we froze can you hear me because you
guys are frozen
i love that stuff
i cut it but he gets up for about a good
minute right here
look at look at that dump truck
here you back okay so
this is great this is going great um
i lost you on a certain note there but i
want to say
uh so so talk about the difference
between writing a book like the zero
gravity and your autobiography which i
loved your autobiography oh
yes apropos nothing came out
it's awesome
[Laughter]
man he gave it all
for this
yeah he's he's livid
dude somebody's getting shot
oh yeah
are they in a room where they have the
best wi-fi this is the second time
they've shut down
[Laughter]
no they need to be in a room with like
the best wi-fi in the house that's
awesome thanks for the tech advice alex
how about some crisis management advice
don't do this interview you dumb [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ]
the wi-fi is the least of your problems
man what have they got going on there
okay what's going on i just opened the
door maybe it'll make a difference she
opened the door
i think they're on dial up i think
just why did this need to be live i mean
why did it need to happen in the first
place true just why why are you like
you're just causing yourself a lot of
heartache here i think alex just was
like it's casual nobody's gonna get
pissed it's just like we just randomly
caught each other on instagram live yeah
i think it was for us
just for the memes
probably the only people that watched i
think this was just for us yeah we're i
think we're only people that cut it up
like this and are enjoying
it to this degree maybe we should upload
this as you know alec baldwin woody
allen best stuff yeah yeah maybe yeah
best watchable version
the open door i cannot
to let the wi-fi breathe
is there any is that
well of course that could work right
wi-fi is a radio signal it can be
obstructed by
walls and everything but interesting the
chances that a thin-ass door is like
what's causing your problem is almost
nothing certainly yeah yeah i love that
though
i'm the tech guy i open the door
it should work now
i can't hear you i can't hear you yet
can you hear me
your wife
must know that when you write a book of
casuals you're going to give her the
business a little bit every now and then
this is so awesome
you say uh
that her credit card was still glowing
from the recent frictions of the credit
did we lose the connection again
[Music]
open a window
yeah
you dumbass
what a stupid idiot stupid
dumb
[ __ ] idiot alec baldwin
that's so stupid
well thanks for going through that ab oh
yeah no problem did you learn anything
did you learn anything interesting over
that album i have more patience than i
thought
any insights into the creative genius of
woody allen no it's just mostly like
alex simpson for
alan he didn't ask him anything about
his love life or anything like that no
he just said that
let me ask you um how young is too young
in your opinion let's say the two people
are in love
how young is too young this seems to be
something that maybe you could tell us
well you know
i i don't really see ages as i refer you
to my film manhattan um yeah i'm a 40
year old dating a 16 year old
i mean that's love you know i i like the
tight little young
bodies of a young girl
right
and i mean they don't they don't know
anything they'll do anything i tell them
right and they don't have a confidence
yet
take for example my step-daughter she
was 12
you know
that's a great i apologize the girl was
17 in the film
and that's in a movie that [ __ ]
put out yeah he's like i'm 40 dating a
17 year old and that's what i'm willing
to say on the record academy
award-winning movie
let's go baby that's what i'm saying
this is the pedo generation straight up
that's this is how we do it
okay let's get to the jordan peterson
[ __ ] because this stuff was wait what do
we have so good oh you got something
good you got a little cam meme here
so what do we got here this is uh alec
baldwin with a gun and woody he is
shooting his career i believe
he's executing his career oh he's alec
is executing his own imd
page
he's giving it all up for his boy woody
love that
powerful man
you gave it all up with the man with a
droopy ass eye dude
[Laughter]
you gave it all up for a man that's got
like three days to live
[Music]
so jordan peterson yes now i'm just
saying okay yeah some of you guys may
have seen this but he had a full-on
meltdown when i was sick with coveted it
was one of my favorite things or maybe
it was before or no it was it happened
the week with
you're talking about the original tweet
about
uh the whole issue
or are you talking about his reaction to
getting banned well he first he got he
tweeted out the most horrible thing
which we talked about right
and then
he got
actually it wasn't even suspension
twitter just sent him a notification
that said erase this tweet
and we'll restore your account i've got
one of those before the softbands yeah
at the same time he joined the daily
wire ben shapiro's um
network they're basically the whole
platform of the day the wire at this
point is hating trans people i feel like
that's basically their
it's the whole right-wing media i mean
this is what they're running on the
midterms on
yeah it's pretty incredible that's why i
don't understand people like
you see that clip of like macy gray
she's like i just want to say it just
happened like yesterday
i just want to say for the record
that trans women aren't real women just
out of nowhere
you can find it decided to
and then and then jk rowling was like
i'm buying all of macy gray's
discography i was like why the [ __ ] are
you
that's like yeah and the turf thing is
real i mean
it's like they think that trans women
are
take away from the real woman experience
which is just so odd to me i mean why do
you care [ __ ] you shut up [ __ ] up
especially when trans people are getting
dog piled by like every conservative
psychopath you know
i just find it so
um so inhuman
what what people like that say and do
but anyway not about that
i just want to
point out
a little weird to hear about macy gray
that's literally a name i haven't heard
yeah i know
pull it up bro
yeah no i know gray she had like she had
like one song and then there was a one
hit wonder from like early two thousand
was this
but the song didn't quite reach me
through the
yeah did you find that clip anyone
i have a point i'm trying to find it oh
okay okay anyway you can trust me it
happened
but anyway
yes so
sorry i'm realizing right now i only
know who macy gray is because she was on
an episode of that so raven when i was a
kid that's that timeline matches up dude
she got so much mileage out of that one
song
pretty incredible yeah and now she's out
here being a turf
she i also saw on tick tock she's like
starting to uh make a tick tock presence
she's like going around handing her new
cds to people dude
[Music]
yeah down at venice beach pretty much
that's like the old scam at um
yeah yeah
new york what is it called
uh my brain is fried from kovid it's
like okay they hand you the cd and then
they're usually like well people usually
tip us like 10 bucks yeah just handing
out their mixtape yeah but anyways i was
just shocked by it oh this is where i
saw it of course deaf noodles
of course yeah definitely always has the
tea
oh yeah everybody's gonna hate me but as
a woman
just because you go change your parts
doesn't make you a woman right sorry
okay nobody asks [ __ ]
okay and pierce more what did you do
yeah is that a piers pierce morgan uh
you feel that interview i know that for
a fact
you know that so
he probably asked he said nobody asked i
mean wait hold on hold on i don't know
it's sincere and i will say this and
everybody's gonna hate me but as a woman
seems like she kind of just threw it out
there based on the very little context i
have just because you go change your
parts doesn't make you mad right sorry
why do you feel that good i just don't
try that why didn't you care why do you
care
just don't get it
so weird oh yeah then the jk rowling let
me find this tweet just to show you what
a piece of [ __ ] she actually is
oh it's not here
never mind
anyway let's talk about jordan what also
bette midler had a good commercial tweet
too i saw that too bet and [ __ ]
midler yeah
we are women who have come together to
say that trans women
are not real women
shut the [ __ ] up nobody cares about you
stupid-ass opinion
oh there's more we get the whole context
that's good and i'm not sure why really
it's it's a bit like this whole issue of
transgenders in sport it's like i
support all trans rights to fairness and
equality except in sports me too but not
what you have
to [ __ ] you sound like oscar the grouch
shut up
physical stuff you blogging a trash can
in sesame street not in pierce morgan
also why is he like that's not true
pierce
say what
he starts he qualifies at all i support
trans rights
do you believe here's morgan
i mean
no i don't believe that
i don't actually goes a little further
back to like
a six minute time stamp
well we're on a tangent here but i guess
it's good just to show how literally
everybody hates trans people these days
transphomia transphobia is like the new
definitely the new homophobia of
of the 90s somehow it feels even worse
though
more hateful more like more acute
violent in a way it seems like the
rhetoric is violent
i mean not to take away from homophobia
because
no need to compare them
how you feel about women you know and
then there would be so many things that
that went into that you know i mean
we're in an era now basically you can't
most public figures are too terrified to
even say what they think a woman is i
know i mean what if i asked you what a
woman what would you say
let's say uh a human being with uh boobs
how are you to start there yeah
you know that's like the normal answer
and it's fine
because it's like look you're talking
about like gender identity studies and
theory about like gender and sex being
separate and she's ignorant about that
that's fine but it's weird how they just
revel in their ignorance like
well in her definition i mean
it's a human being with boobs
okay
i boobs
trans women you know they'll get breast
surgery and they'll have boobs so i
guess they are women well the definition
is that simplistic i'm just you're right
exactly you're right little she's
actually thought about this
and well they're they're basically
they're the same thing those goes like
oh you know what a woman is
it's like a woman's a woman that's what
they that's all they say but it's
actually more interesting than that
more nuanced than that when you think
about it and it's just weird how they
revel in their ignorance yeah
i mean the dictionary is quite
straightforward it just sounds like an
adult female right
now a lot of people yeah see that now
that's a little getting confusing oh
she's she they that's good that's good
and i'm not sure why really it's it's a
bit why are you even asking her about it
she's like a crackhead bro
is this the conversation be having with
macy gray
what does she think about the ukraine
war and renda let's get her take on
other hot topic issues the whole issue
of transgenders in sport it's like i
can't i the [ __ ] does macy great even
talking about transgender people in
sports like i'm still baffled
she's
on anything she's proven that she hasn't
she has nothing to say about it yeah
yeah she's not an expert she's she's
truly and fully ignorant about it and
she's basically said so
women's rights to fairness and equality
me too but not where you have
obvious physical superior bodies
right
you sound like marge
get out of here with that marge ass
sounded
fair do's kind of looking like marge too
to me it sounds like shoe nice's marge
specifically yeah not even the reason i
like that i like that
and i i will say this and everybody's
gonna hate me but as a woman she brought
that out just because you go change your
parts doesn't make you a woman saying as
a woman is so condescending to trans
people
it's it's like absolutely keeping it's
yeah it's like claiming the gender
before your point even to like spew
hatred
it's just it's so
evil
i do think it's i don't know why people
point this out too and i don't know what
this is about but
with all of because you're right there's
definitely a huge upsurge in like the
last year or two of transphobia and
people getting like really
intensely upset about all of this the
conversation is almost exclusively about
trans women
nobody cares about trans men nobody
seems to be like offended by that
they're scared by that at all you know
what i think it is i'll be honest
oh i don't know if this is true you guys
get mad at me when i say stuff like this
but people like stephen crowder and ben
shapiro and all these guys they hate
trans women because they're all scared
that they're attracted to them bro
and i know you guys hate you guys hate
when i say like all the whatever i think
that that's part of it bro why don't
people care about trans men you're
absolutely right oh they do this whole
thing's about elliott
whatever the last name page so that's
not entirely true
but most of it is about trans women i
think you're right
crowder's afraid that he
that he's attracted see i i don't agree
with you
blanket stating that however
i do think
crowder
crowd crowder no but well you know
what's crazy dude how many of these
there's something there how many well
there's two specifically but it's a
pattern at this point alex jones and
nick fuentes both got caught with trans
porn yep on their [ __ ] phone i mean
it's a real thing and like i think i
think people probably just take issue
with you not
hedging that saying
that there are plenty of people that
aren't closeted because i think
the the way it's been articulated to me
that actually makes sense is that when
you say that it's making it seem like
it's
it's the
the queer and gay people that are the
problem like they're creating a problem
of their own rather than straight cis
people just being hateful and bigoted
and that's why
they're acting this way um okay i think
it's true i mean there are plenty of
heterosexual people that are just
[ __ ] bigots you know what i mean
but again with crowder i really do
i do think there is something there i
don't know man yeah and it's another way
to say too to agree with you is like if
people like jordan are making such a big
deal out of this so it must be affecting
them on a personal level dude his
response jordan peterson you're gonna
say his response to this is so
far
beyond reasonable yeah he's like all the
way
in another solar system in terms of
gauging his response and the best part
is that like elliott page hasn't even
set doesn't say anything to him doesn't
know anything about him there's
literally never been
he's obsessed he's obsessed with elliot
page
so let's watch the jordan piercing
because this this is really amazing
and i feel so justified in erasing those
jordan uh clips
when i did and this was before he really
went [ __ ] nuts
so i feel like you know redeemed in a
way that i erased those [ __ ] episodes
now i guess no this does
kind of go count like i said earlier
that it's almost always trans women
being attacked in this case it actually
is a trans man yeah so it's not
universal i guess i should make that
clear but it does seem like the vast
majority of it without trans women right
that's a good point i agree
um
sex would you say olivia
oh i couldn't see it while i typed it
just like you you called covid
thank you dude you called jordan thank
you i see things people need to
understand that about me i see things
people don't give me credit for seeing
the things i do but you do olivia and i
love that about you thank you thank you
i do i do
all right so let's talk because this
[ __ ] is nuts you guys are gonna love
this if you haven't seen it
so jordan peterson he got suspended on
twitter
for the horrible tweet that he made
um
and where's that original tweet just to
give context
it was just it was so vile it was so
messed up it was like one of the meanest
most hateful tweets i've seen
a public figure actually tweet out
um
and we did a whole segment about it but
let me just read it to you guys to
refresh
remember
you're muted
50 [ __ ] memberships 5-0
oh thank you jordan
also we got apparently uh we got 50
from granny's meat curtains everybody
damn granny's meat curtains thank you
the genital region was who's got that
sweet tweet
i'm just going to pretend like that was
jordan that did that
i'm just gonna
that's the real jordan that just
glorious uh
120p
so he said it was a picture of remember
when pride was a sin and ellen page
which i guess that's like
dead naming
it's like using his old name just right
in birth yeah
it's like just to be offensive yeah for
real like he changed his name he changed
his name when someone legally changed
their name you don't call them by their
old name he's just being a dick but then
the weird the craziest thing for me was
he goes and ellen page just had her
breasts removed by a criminal physician
and you know
elliott is like in his 30s
fully developed successful accomplished
person
and even
him making a decision for his own health
is unacceptable to jordan 35 he is i
find that so interesting because the
dialogue is always about like kids what
are we doing to the kids this is a 35
year old man who made a decision about
himself and jordan's not down with that
i mean what the [ __ ] somebody you forget
to ask
yeah where's that that was so good
there was a great meme
of a doctor saying i consent elliot's
saying i consent and then jordan oh
somebody actually made that yeah is
there somebody forgot to ask you i was
really good
so anyway
um he got suspended for that
but it wasn't a real suspension they
just said erase the tweet and we'll re
we'll restore your account
so in response instead of erasing it and
getting his account back
he put out a 14 minute video
and when she breaks down every single
word of that tweet he says quote i would
rather die
than erase the tweet
how about that huh
duh
[Music]
up yours
uh peterson last claim to acquit twitter
after getting upset yeah then he wasn't
he couldn't jerk off to the
to the overweight sports illustrated
model and um he said he was gonna quit
twitter after that but
now he's saying he'll die for twitter
right i died for this [ __ ]
sorry not beautiful
i find it endlessly interesting how
important twitter is to these like
[ __ ] freaks
um
here we go guys get ready
hello everyone let me guess oh it's on
this page look at this [ __ ] put
on a suit
this is the most important moment of his
life
because twitter said delete look at this
[ __ ] guy what's scary is it has 300
000 likes guys and 3 million views
people really like this channel his
family wait no there's this is [ __ ] up
oh yeah
it's so [ __ ] up that people agree with
him and think that this is interesting
this guy
this guy is the
titan he's the great thinker on the
right
a few days ago i penned an irritated
tweet
in response to one of the latest
happenings that that's putting it mildly
irritated it was
it was
barbaric it was inhuman
panda [ __ ] completely unhinged
totally unprompted somebody needs to
line up that doctor and kill them by
death squad
on the increasingly heated culture
warfront
in response to the decision of an
actress
actor
named ellen
elliott
nice stick bro
but an actor an actress elliot ellen ah
just so hard to keep track
by the way lucky was so upset about
the removal of
the breasts
and it's a criminal act it's like do you
know about breast reduction surgery
well as many people have pointed out let
me see if i can find the pictures
because you're gonna love this mr
hairline it's actually a thing did you
see that
he very clearly got a hairline surgery
pull it up
i didn't know jordan was that vain loser
how dare you interfere with god's will
to you for you to be bald [ __ ] you yeah
they're saying literally gender is
gender birming surgery that's what it is
check it out sex bro you were bald as
[ __ ] what's up player
very clear
why are you
here here's another photo of him back in
the day
oh my god look at him dude he looks
[ __ ] up
[Music]
it's just
had this guy he looks much better now
and he probably feels a lot more
confident and better about himself and
you know and more masculine it's almost
like you know it works it works isn't
vanity as thin
oh got him good point ab thank you
this video is crazy i can't believe he
actually did a 15-minute video about
this [ __ ] is nuts you guys
uh
delete
i am employing this awkward and
impossible naming style
because it's not it's it's not
impossible you know what's cool what you
could just not talk about him
like that is something you could do not
required this man has a phd in
psychology and he says it's impossible
it's beyond human means
to keep track of two names
i can't do it
it's impossible
insane
it's insane
now apparently mandatory and i'm
probably doing it wrong it's not
mandatory bro are you going to jail
are you [ __ ]
are you are you being locked up no it's
not mandatory you could do whatever the
[ __ ] you want you're just a dick that's
what people are saying mandatory
wrong
nonetheless as you're doing it wrong is
the whole point of what has been made
mandatory
but also i'm trying to make a point i
love that this is like a three cam shot
this is a this is his address to the
union bro this is insane this is intense
okay
it's just twitter dude
it's just twitter
they just said erase the tweet man
i've essentially been banned from
twitter no as a consequence
i say banned
although technically i have been
suspended but the suspension will not be
lifted unless i delete the hateful tweet
in question bridge stop it was hateful
even if you think you're right you're
angry you're hateful bro shut up
you're a hateful little bitch-ass
[ __ ] loser dork you seen that old
picture you dork
pencil-headed [ __ ]
i just want to point out hassan made a
good point in comparison he was banned
for a week for saint cracker and he
didn't cry about it right he didn't make
a three shot dramatic this is where i
this is where we make our stand
here and no further
i will not erase the tweet
i will die no at the foot of twitter
headquarters
no
mandatory and i would rather die than do
that
he would rather that's just so good
this man was willing to quit he said
he's quitting twitter last week and now
he's dying for twitter
it's pretty serious i'm dying
and hopefully it will not come to that
although who the hell knows in these
increasingly strange days yes what was
it that i said
that caused such a fuss
and that fuss is just beginning
and even more importantly and
complexly what exactly was it that i
said
that resulted in the ban
here's the tweet in question
remember when pride was a sin
and ellen page
just had her breasts removed
by a criminal physician
then a link to a story that detailed out
the
happenings the response from twitter
quote
violating our rules against hateful
conduct
you may not promote violence against
threaten or harass other people on the
basis of race ethnicity national origin
sexual orientation gender gender
identity religious affiliation age
disability or serious disease
by clicking delete
you acknowledge that your tweet violated
the twitter rules
yep delete
if you think we've made a mistake submit
an appeal to us please note that should
you do so dude it's just twitter bro you
made a three cam shot bitching and
crying about a tweet dude you loser
have some dignity man
your account will remain locked while we
review
your appeal
let's take this apart
first
it is clearly the case that i did not
promote violence against
or threaten
anyone no and it said harass too he's
ignoring that it said herrera
with my missus
so that leaves the arguably lesser sin
of harass okay you know let's assume
since i wasn't informed that that was
the crime
and further harassment on the basis of
so-called gender identity sits twitter
did not do me the favor of actually
specifying my crime and there are many
possibilities on that front we
unfortunately have to guess at why this
is okay i've said so many effective
things i don't even i don't even know
what i was banned for
and because twitter didn't send me a
letter and come to my
sit down with me and explain why my
tweets were hurtful and mean
like i'm a 12 year old
then i don't understand
what is that i will [ __ ] die
for that tweet
buckle
big problem in and of itself and also
indicative of the utter carelessness of
the twitter organization with regard to
the propriety of its own sensorial
actions
i should at least know exactly what i
did wrong shut up dude what are you
[ __ ] 12
shut up
shut up sit down
go to your room jordan you [ __ ]
pathetic weasel clean it you're gonna go
and clean your room you're grounded
i can't believe this guy actually takes
himself seriously man it's crazy
if i'm required to acknowledge that my
tweet violated the twitter rules
what rules you sons of [ __ ]
what rules you sons of [ __ ]
i'll [ __ ] die for this [ __ ]
[Laughter]
oh god
dude it's twitter chill bro
anyway that you got that sound drop
right zach what i did wrong exactly the
restroom
if i'm required to acknowledge that my
tweet violated the twitter rules
what rules you sons of [ __ ]
i love that he does have it by the way
he got like
50 sounds okay guys video yeah
because you know it's just like some
random twitter rules enforcer who's like
oh yeah this is violating the rules what
rules you sons of [ __ ]
what do you mean what rules you know
exactly it said harassing on the base of
gender
stop just erase the tweet move on
exactly
precisely
because such things matter when the
accusations start flying
so what did i say that might constitute
harassment
well many things hypothetically okay oh
okay good we're cool we can shut it down
what room let's begin with [ __ ] yeah
thank you love that
remember when pride
was a sin
although that is merely a factual
statement because under the oral rules
applicable even a decade ago pride
was a sin
and had been recognized as perhaps the
cardinal sin for thousands of years
previously this is like the most
intentionally obtuse
point ever like
remember when pride was a sin you're
talking about gay pride people being
proud of who they are instead of being
ashamed and embarrassed who they are
the same kind of pride you might have in
your child who play
got good grades
we're not talking about sinful pride
we're not talking about you know the
proverbial sin of pride which is like
hubris which is like that's exactly over
over love for yourself over confidence
for yourself not listening to others
there's a sin of pride which i think if
anyone's committing it might be you
um
the how can you conflate those you're a
doctor stop acting so
obtuse you [ __ ] know the difference
between the sin pride hubris and being
proud of something i mean how [ __ ]
dumb bro you you really think the people
that watch your thing is dumb
shut the [ __ ] up
pride
gay pride
what the [ __ ] dude
can i uh throw in another point
his audio is dog [ __ ]
i heard it like clip in that audio audio
three different audio
audio audio audio so
[ __ ] your [ __ ] you jordan [ __ ] your
audio
thank you zach
that's an important that's the that's
the cardinal sin right there that is
when you're recording a video flipping i
mean you got three three cameras set up
and you're gonna have [ __ ]
audio on bro good point bruh
pride is that remember when pride was a
sin it's still the same you dumbass and
you're doing it right now sons of
[ __ ] you're sitting right now
you [ __ ]
you [ __ ] ass apple cider drinking
[ __ ]
stroke having sons of [ __ ]
i liked jordan better when he was
addicted to benzos just say that
[ __ ]
[Music]
i don't like sober jordan it's not fun
i agree
it still might be regarded as
unacceptable to the woke authoritarian
moralists who now insist for example
that we celebrate
pride month not hour or a day hey are
you doing shtick it's a whole month who
needs a whole month pride month don't
even get me started on block history
month
who needs a month where's my white pride
month month
he's doing like a stand-up routine now
a month one day maybe a month that's a
sin
too much pride
wait
pride month not hour or day or what hour
is that what he wants pride hour that's
all he wants for them
pride hour guys that's all listen
you guys get one hour
he wants a pride purge you have one day
a year get it out of your system yeah he
goes okay ready
okay go
you get one hour
and then you're all being rounded up
after that
no more pride after one hour you hit one
hour
one hour
enjoy it while it lasts you [ __ ]
sinner
it'll be called
the no homo hour no homo for one hour
you can
it's not gay
for this one hour where pride is no
longer a sin i'm going to tell my
daughter i love her and that i'm proud
of all the work she's done because
otherwise it's a sin pride
what an idiot
but month
and to have literally called it pride
month
instead of lgbt plus month or whatever
else alphabet acronym dude you think
you're really making a point here and
it's actually just embarrassing this is
like i'm 13 i'm 14 and this is deep
level of thinking
it's nuts this guy is a celebrated
thinker
which is currently insisted upon as the
only acceptable enlightened
terminology
i don't regard pride as a virtue it has
been classically i won't call it pride
month
for example
i don't call black history month black
history month it's outrageous to force
my compel my speech
i call it black folks month
i find that easier to say
there's a sin i don't see that sexual
orientation or sexual desire of any sort
is something to celebrate or to take
pride yeah because you're straight and
you've never been prosecuted for being
gay you never had people wanting to kill
you literally drag you
but at the end of a car till you die
you've never had people tell you you're
going to hell because of the way you
were born
yeah
of course you you don't think it should
be and it's incredible that you're
actually have so little empathy there's
so little insight into the human
condition that you consider yourself a
phd of psychology and you're telling a
whole swath of people that they
shouldn't
that you don't understand they're very
simple to relate to human experience
you have the [ __ ] maturity of a
you have the maturity of a
old old
old
bigoted man
okay that's right on the nose that's
literally what what's going on here
no
no
oh thank you happy pride second oh
that's the same well the same icon they
must have just changed their name to
happy secret happy pride second guys
thank you
so that's a hundred total legend the
legendary prize
i'm no
to take that pride and shove it up your
ass mandatory you just committed a sin
on a hundred innocent people you get
that flag out of here
i like how he says pride's a sin just
say you hate gay people bro just saying
you sons of [ __ ] just say being gay
is a sin
what rules you sons of [ __ ]
well
what a loser
this guy has the maturity of a
finely aged xanax
take a zany bar
hey jordan wouldn't it be nicer just to
take a zany bar and chill
life's so hard you're so stressed out
maybe just take a zany bar and relax
take a nap
watch your shows
it'd be nice right
and so what i said was merely a fact
now it's possible that i hurt someone's
feelings
because i pointed out that pride goes
before for example
a fall
but i don't care you're talking about
hubris we're talking about greek pride
bro why are you so obtuse you know the
difference between pride
and like mythological
tragic hubris pride stop bro shut the
[ __ ] up you read all day
supposedly you know the difference yeah
here here is the
uh sort of explanation of the sin pride
the one that he's supposedly talking
about and you tell me if you think this
sounds like um
him or the people that he's criticizing
yeah uh
in a pathological sense uh it is a
rational belief that one is essentially
better superior or more important than
others uh
despising their merits and excessively
admiring oneself as godlike refusing to
acknowledge one's limits faults or
wrongs dude that is [ __ ] so
interesting that he's literally
committing
he's accusing people of yes this video
is like the embodiment of the sin of
pride exactly his mind is not open he's
convinced he's right
um and and and it's actually just
resulting in in hate and the meaning of
other people this is the sin of pride
personified and [ __ ] you
if jordan was in the movie seven i'm
pretty sure his ass would be like up on
a cross or some [ __ ] as one of the sins
of pride
that's awesome dude
whoa this is what i'm saying dude your
mind on g too much jesus [ __ ] you're
buying up bro it's scrambling your ass
telling you man
this is nice
would do it again and then can you
define the just pride like i'm proud of
myself because i because i didn't
because i didn't have a pizza today
uh let's see richard taylor defined
pride as the justified the justified
love of oneself as opposed to false
pride or narcissism similarly saint
augustine
is a catholic saint defined it as the
love of one's own excellence
or others you could have pride in others
sure yeah
i did not put my dick anywhere near my
dog
i believe it i think it might be is it
what you're saying is because yeah
i've never done anything i don't think
it's a sin
or a commandment a commandment
uh i don't know i don't know if it could
spread because pride is a commandment
isn't it
no no no it's one of the seven deadly
sins
it'd be lust right lust gluttony greed
sloth wrath envy and pride why is
[ __ ] okay let's not get you you've
seen you've seen come on you know this
you've watched a full metal alchemist
that you can't [ __ ] animals as a sin
i did not come on like oh the deadly
seven cent yeah yeah no i know i know i
forgot about that whole thing
all right let's keep going jordan you're
doing great you're doing great jordan
you're doing great sweetie i'd also
consider it my duty to warn those who
are about to fall into a pit
that the path they are on leads suddenly
downhill dude it's crazy how he's
describing his life trajectory
he's been on a downward hill into this
sin of pride and he's fallen
down into the black hole of pride
this man is a loss
it's
lost i think it's funny he just said but
that's beauty
duty duty
that got you duty duty zach [ __ ] you
good jordan bitch-ass peterson duty-ass
jordan
probably not the reason that i was
banned from twitter although as i said i
am in the position
of having to guess
no that wasn't it jordan
next phrase to interrogate
and ellen page
now why did i stop there
because in all
likelihood it was this seemingly
innocuous phrase
including the name
of a well-known actress there i'm in
trouble again
that likely resulted in my ban i
committed the fatal crime of what has
come to be known in the appalling
sensorial terminology of the insane
activists as
dead naming which is the act of
referring to someone who has
transitioned another hated i love that
he's defending like he he's pretending
like he didn't use
his former name to insult like that was
a very conscious decision i mean
i don't think that's why he got banned i
think the whole tweet in general calling
the doctor a criminal and all that [ __ ]
i think it was all very isis you know
what i mean
um but this is kind of what's been going
on between the two of them summarized
jordan says you took everything from me
and elliot says i don't even know who
you are and that's pretty much what's
been going on between the two of them
love that love that for you jordan
by the way elliot was in umbrella
academy loved that show the third season
just came out really good
juno is my favorite movie in the entire
world juno yeah that's right i love juno
that's nuts
that
i can't even believe that was a long
time ago
[Music]
duty piece of jargon and slogan by the
name and by the inference the gender
really the sex that everyone knew them
by previously and in the case of ellen
slash elliott that millions of people
recognized and knew
so i should have either called him her
they elliot instead of ellen
although as we will discover that would
have made it impossible for me to say
what i wanted to and need to say in the
remaining phrases i need not to say it's
a problem would bother those who are
objecting to my speech in the first
place
yeah um
did you did it on purpose to be a dick
let's just be real
precisely
the next phrase is
just had her breasts removed
this bit suffers
from a very similar problem
i employed the forbidden pronoun her
when elliot ellen is now to be regarded
as a he
or else
but there's a conundrum here to say the
least and not just for me although i
have been banned because of it was
elliot slash ellen a she
or a he
or ellen or elliot when she or he or
they
that's elliot or alien by the way i
think you could benefit from a gender
studies class i mean
what what is this sentence that he's
trying to spit out right now this is i
think he's just confused i think he just
needs an intro course on gender studies
clearly he's ridiculously ignorant but
he
knows what he's doing wrong and he's
doing it purposefully so if he just let
himself do things correctly it would be
a lot easier i think for the rest of the
world and him
yeah he's being intentionally obtuse
about everything just to be a dick
and um well hold on guys it's actually
pride minute so if i would just hope
everybody how your head's about your
head minute dan get your ass over here
yeah baby
yeah get that dick out son
about to act up
all right probably five minutes over get
it off stop stop stop no more of that
[ __ ] no more of that gay [ __ ]
insane
pride minute
that was a fun minute
look forward to it next year
[Laughter]
had his or her or their breasts removed
if he or she was a he if she or he or
she are they
or is there's it
i can't deal with it
then why was it necessary to have the
mastectomy
and how could those i'm writing to make
sense of what i was saying if it was his
breasts that were removed because gender
has nothing to do with biology dude i
don't know why why we have to explain
this like you know the difference it's
been explained to you
and all your dumb ass friends a
gajillion times
gender is different from biological sex
okay
you're missing that very
come on i mean he knows he's not missing
of course he does i i actually go
further i mean i think i think
he [ __ ] kamikazed with that tweet
intentionally i don't think it's a
coincidence that he was announced that
he was joining the daily wire like a few
days after all this went down
and within
moments after that has this slickly
produced you know video cam
yeah uh
he's doing this for attention he's
antagonizing intentionally yeah it's the
and then actually there's other people
which we'll get into but like dave rubin
went and got himself banned
who's gay by the way the most
self-hating
i love dave rubin's story man that man
he's definitely going to hell too yeah
oh man we're getting lots of gifted
stuff but i miss
what did we do where would we be without
members
50 gifted songs another 50 is that that
isn't the same person again is it
it might be it's jordan peterson
is this the same guy who does subs go up
this must be subs go up i don't know
this is like
this is our this is our secret george
soros who's like funding the podcast
george dude that'd be badass if george
was a fan i'll take some of that george
soros one and give a [ __ ] send it over
come on baby daddy needs a new scorpion
chair
yes
sir female breasts that were removed
if they were male breasts
then why were they removed
if they were female breasts and had
therefore become objectionable to the
degree that surgery generally reserved
for cancer treatment was required was
morally obligatory then wasn't eliot
still alan and he's still she
i [ __ ] got him
i untangled this crazy ass puzzle of
yours
because they had boobs
yeah because he's just ignoring the
obvious it's just that that's the
defining it's just he's on the same page
as macy gray actually yeah titties make
the woman titties big beautiful titties
the end-all be-all of what a woman is if
you take the tits away
you're no longer a woman what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude you're some kind of
freak
you twisted yourself up into some crazy
pretzel jordan
gender and sex are different that's it
man it's really not complicated i think
you have a phd
i'm just some [ __ ] idiot with brain
damage with you
say 10 iq points lower and you still got
it yeah my brain is glossed over
laminated over
and i still get it
how could i possibly have written that
sentence in any sensible manner
whatsoever yeah because you wrote it
well simultaneously making my point
understandably
and not breaking twitter rules against
so-called airline when exactly did you
become a
paired fellow hold on a second
or internet die
i see lots of f's in the chat yeah oh
i think it's coming back yo i'm telling
you man we're supposed to have that 99.9
uptime i feel like this is the second
time it's happening i didn't know 99.9
uptime i think we do need to look into
this because uh
when it was a one-off i was willing to
yeah we're we're back everybody's saying
we're back sorry about that all right
had a little hiccup here yeah i don't
know why that happened so it's happening
too much we have a dedicated
teeth one or t3 or fiber i don't know
dedicated optic line that we literally
spent months before we moved in
laying pipe
yes we laid by baby you know don't be
late i'm fighting that pride minute dude
you know what i'm saying should we open
a door maybe oh that's a good point yeah
open the door that's a good point oh
there's no doors oh somebody said open
the trunk true open the trunk
zach
yeah you want to come into my car close
the trunk
that's a twist that i like i like that
[Laughter]
jordan this is so good but you know the
the unexpected consequence of this is
just that he really exposed himself as
the lunatic he is he's totally masked
off
and he's turned himself into a such a
meme the man has no dignity left and
it's just great i love that he was
definitely ellen at some point in the
past
yeah or so indicate all his her them
their film credits
well all those have to be re-shot since
they employed the hated dead name no no
nope
in the new season
they may change the
credits i've actually seen that happen
before i'm actually i'm actually just
started uh watching umbrella academy and
they're already changed there
in the first season yeah so they did do
that
right it's it's literally just changing
the type
on it yeah
but obviously um
he had in transition so
he was a woman
in the first two seasons and then the
third one just came out after the
transition
and it started with him playing a woman
like he did in the plus the last two
and then they had a whole thing where
he like it's part they made a part of
the story it was pretty good
it didn't feel too forced
um where he was like i'm changed my name
i'm a guy this is who i've always been
it wasn't that it you know i was a
little tricky obviously subject matter
but they they found a somewhat uh
graceful way graceful way to do it okay
nice
but it's [ __ ] impossible
up yours what do we need to go back to
your
high school yearbooks and change the
photo
it's insane
what do you need to go back into your
mom's vagina come back out
i'll leave that question up to you to
answer
that doesn't exist by the way that dead
name category except in the sensorial
and adult minds of a tiny fraction of
insanely narcissistic and increasingly
dangerous trans activists
i love that they're so dangerous bro
what is the danger people are literally
just asking you not to be a dick
what is the danger
what are you threatened by also i love
that the consequent the dangerous uh
consequence is that
one of his tweets they just asked him to
erase one of his tweets
this is impossible
catastrophic
danger to our society
twitter made me erase a tweet
uh s go up like a scorpion chair just
donated 50 subbies didn't they i think
and it's it's george doris again george
zorro man my boy
thank you dude
oh yeah let's not forget the
keemstar's great
uh tweet here ethan h3h3 equals the
george soros of youtube yeah he's not
anti-semitic
that's a totally just
totally normal thing to say and i'm sure
he picked george soros for no particular
reason and not you know uh any of the
other
hundreds of billionaires that completely
you know control our politics george
yeah specifically yeah george soros do
you think i hate jewish people i don't
know read this tell me what you think
this definitely strikes me as
anti-semitic eh but you know what maybe
i'm being sensitive maybe he's
a george soro fan
and he does george soros doesn't do a
lot of charity and he's doing it as a
compliment to you i hate the jews
that makes it harder to believe when he
says like that okay maybe not anyway
back to
back to jordan
when precisely was it incumbent on me to
switch my terminology in regard to
elliott slash ellen
so that i was not engaging in hateful
conduct dude you're such an idiot
when he changed his name yeah
when when
are you [ __ ] not before not before
they came out as trans yeah how would
you know how would you know but then
afterwards you know you could be
respectful and just do that
right
it's very it's really complicated stuff
and how can i describe the fact that
someone who was once a woman and really
still is had her breasts cut off because
she he yeah i mean that's just that's so
[ __ ] up it's [ __ ] off yeah
i mean
this is just no different is this just
straight up violent bigoted hatred and
it's funny because
in this country we have such a dark
history of homophobia and racism and all
the terrible things that we've done here
and
it's funny because everyone just seems
to think oh never again we're never
going to do that again we're you know
we've people are changed and and here i
mean this is it this is open
hateful violent
transphobia i mean these are people that
exist
they're born the way they were
and um
he's turned it into a culture war where
where
it's like they can't they're not just
existing it's like
their existence is
a existential threat to him
to the point where
i i feel like they're close to
justifying violence to you know what i
mean like they're getting there
yep
because when you frame them as like a
threat right then it's easy to justify
violence
yeah and i think that's that's actually
where they want to go with this that's
where it's going
they there them had fallen prey to a
viciously harmful fad
without using the appropriate sex link
pronoun and the real name of the real
person
to whom this was
really done with his her their voluntary
but unfortunate acquiescence and so it
was impossible to communicate what had
happened to my audience without
apparently running a foul of the
impossible and observed rules that now
hypothetically govern morality itself
wait did i miss the part where he
compares the surgery to the nazi death
camps oh i think it's coming up it's
coming up yeah
that's awesome
days of the degenerated postmodern and
marxist ethos there it is
my favorite
it's such a worst salad too that
postmarks and
the
modern pokes marx system of the
[ __ ]
neo fashion post-modern neo-marxist
uh
blah blah blah literally no one even
knows what that means bro even like i
don't even think you know what that
means how impossible it is abide by
or else
and you might object alan
elliot is an adult 30-something and
fully capable of making up his her their
own mind
like you did it right the first time
you're like one you're going out of your
way yeah the whole thing is
but i love this like okay i i will give
you that he's a grown person
35 years old but here let's see what's
wrong with it
about such things and she he they are
welcome from the liberal and the
libertarian position to go to hell in a
handbasket as she he they
see fit
and fair enough to some degree
and fair enough to some degree however
but i think the government needs to
intervene into people's lives
but i don't believe it is either merely
pikayun or inappropriate to point out
that ellen slash elliott who is quite a
good actor slash actress
is also a ritual model
for emulation
being a star with all the privileges and
let us point out the responsibilities
that go along with that so by ac
quiescent to this surgery and by
publicizing it by insisting upon the
sanctity and the moral virtue of his her
their new expensive dangerous and
medically enhanced identity and by
participating in the whole identity
sharad alan elliott has undoubtedly with
his her their so-called courage dude is
it that you're making you're not even
like trying making you're making it hard
to watch
like just from like a from a dick from
addiction from an orator standpoint like
just pick a [ __ ] pronoun and stick
with it like i get you're trying to be
offensive but yeah but you're losing me
a little bit yeah let's just come on
let's come on bro just be offense just
stick to whatever you like the best
there he has to dehumanize him every
chance he gets
someone said this isn't the same person
who was on your pocket yeah i totally
agree totally agree
yeah his his uh his hair plugs grew in a
lot more thicker i looked back because
some people thought that maybe he got
the surgery after seeing your hairline
right so i went back to the episode and
i think he got it actually right before
then
he did it in preparation yeah yeah
true exactly
oh he confirmed it yeah i agree he was
not this crazy when he came on the show
i mean
he was dabbling a little bit and
he was definitely more
he wasn't so masked off if he was
feeling all this [ __ ] well certainly
yeah
i think he did but i think he was
far better at
or
had some sort of incentive to not
necessarily uh
go all out with well yeah now he has a
full financial incentive he's being paid
too right just look at the description
he has like donation links daily wire
links oh is that right
yeah it's so obvious that he's doing
everything for money
let's see
refusing to back down by the way he
wrote this about himself refusing to
back down dr jordan b peterson calls out
the woke moralist
as he deconstructs the tweet that put
him in the censor's crosshair
read more here at the daily wire
do you
need more details
twit what book cam do you see his first
social link too
twitter uh let's see twitter censored
him but the voice of jordan peterson can
still be heard with exciting new
exclusive content at daily wire plus oh
no scroll down
support this channel like his actual
social media courses links social
twitter let's go he cares about twitter
so much man
i love that for him
so is he still
he's just locked out like his account
isn't banned he just can't tweet until i
mean this is great this is good for
everybody honestly
how long how long time do you think he
won't delete the tweet for well they
first of all they said pending a review
you can erase it and get them banned now
or you can wait for the review to go
through yeah right so it might just end
up being a non
like he might just have it lifted
without having to delete it
wait but he's already in this
jordan pinned this comment so peterson
puts out
the kind of inflammatory tweet that will
obviously get you suspended on twitter
then releases a video calling like
acting like a martyr for free speech and
by complete coincidence the daily wire
announces he's their newest commentator
doesn't this all seem a little too
contrived
he pinned that
well i see that he replied to it so
maybe he pinned it because he epically
ownaged this person yeah here's his
response you'll notice that a week went
by
post tweet before twitter acted
are you suggesting i orchestrated the
fact that twitter banned me on the same
day i partnered with daily wire
how could i possibly do that sorry bucko
that was just luck on my part and
stupidity on theirs
nice but i don't know it was luck i like
that he admits oh interesting it was
very lucky for me that i am getting all
this media attention right as i have
this uh big announcement today it's
actually good news he's saying dude sons
of [ __ ] curious he's actually seems
to be happy that it happened yeah
and remember the white house itself has
tweeted out every indication of
believing in the courage of those who
transition
enticed many a poor confused adolescent
girl most likely
to blame her emergent pubescent
self-consciousness confusion i don't
understand his theory he thinks that
people trans people are just faking it
like people are willing to go undergo
surgery just because it like it's a fad
i mean you're crazy to think that
well he is crazy but like what's your
theory dude
the white house has applauded the
courage of trans people what's what what
what the you you [ __ ] canadian what
the [ __ ] up
why are you even commenting on that
there you go get him dan
since zach mentioned the audio i can't
stop paying attention to all the flaws
in it and it seems like when he zooms in
it seems like it's a different audio
track like it's not even eclipsed but
yeah it's not even like the same volume
interesting
duty
dirty
duty
some would say he did a
transition on his audio surgery
it's a it's a blast it's a it's a sin
against god let the audio be what it is
it was born terrible let it be terrible
no audio enhancing cuts
and discomfort on being born in the
wrong body and believing that the
courageous self-affirming and morally
admirable root is hormonal treatment
subjugation to a lifetime of expensive
medical complications hey how about mind
your own [ __ ] business
let's start there jordan peterson
how does this even affect you in the
slightest way
what happened to just mind your own
[ __ ] business bro
it has nothing to do with you at all
education how delightfully profitable is
that and misery
and i believe firmly that ellen
slash elliot or whatever the hell her
name or his name is dude you're so angry
at him he doesn't even [ __ ] know who
you are
you [ __ ] loser dude as bear's
moral culpability for that
and finally with regard to the final
phrase
criminal physician i must say that i've
had some post-coital sodas
it's like when you [ __ ] someone and then
you're like oh i regret it like how many
of those nights have you been having
lately jordan well it just in general
yeah it's he's basically he literally is
saying he he got his nut yeah he nutted
off of being transphobic and late in
layman's turns post not clear yeah he
got post not clarity after he flew and
he was busted his load yeah and then
he's like i went too far calling the
doctor
or you said poised coidol you [ __ ]
weirdo she's [ __ ] such a freaking
dude
with regard to the final phrase i think
that's a slip too because i think i must
say that i've had some post-coital so to
speak regrets so to speak
i cannot believe you just said
post-coital say that i've had some i got
my nut
being trans my i get off i'm being
transphobic
post benzo clarity more like yeah
i just came out of my benzo haze and i
had a moment of clarity
anyway i'll see y'all later
post-coital
post-coital clarity
about that phrase
it is clearly the case that the surgical
operation performed by the butchers who
butchered elliot slash ellen was legal
so was it criminal
or not
were the operations undertaken by the
fascist physicians who carried out the
nazi medical experiments legal
yes
bro you really
are so out of control
i mean here let's just start if you want
to compare it to nazi
uh medical treatment
well for one
elliott is consenting participant i mean
we can start there that seems like a
pretty big difference
right
was this a poi was this a post-coital
slip up too about the nazi
yes concentration camps i gotta go back
here this shit's nuts
was it criminal
or not
were the operations undertaken by the
fascist physicians who carried out the
nazi medical experiments legal
yes
under the laws of the time
but were they criminal
i'll leave that question up to you today
i'll leave that question to you if you
have the courage to answer
were nazis war criminals i leave that to
you
i'm not comfortable answering that
yeah dude one is a willing participant
the other is a uh tortured a medical
subject so post-coital pretty
interesting comparison
nazi physicians and their assistants
forced prisoners into participating they
did not willingly volunteer well of
course not and no consent was given for
the procedures typically the experiments
were conducted without anesthesia and
resulted in death trauma disfigurement
or permanent disability
and as such are considered examples of
medical torture
yep
i don't think that's what happened in
elliot's case i would say there's a
difference pretty big difference
actually
pretty interesting comparison though
buddy
are the nazis criminals i'm not
comfortable answering that question
but i will say that the doctor who
operated on ellie it is
at least the nazis were trying to get to
some truth in medicine
you know those nazi uh
those nazi medical tests really advanced
medicine
there was a lot of merit to them
post-coital
i mean they were gonna die
they were gonna die anyway might as well
put them to good use post-coital we
could have put those titties to good use
we could have put those titties to good
use
i could have sucked those dry
post-coital
i need some post-coital clarity on them
titties oh that's terrific please stop
and further
perhaps it might be objected
what about the damage done by
hypothetically leaving those confused
about their identity to dwell in their
confusion aren't we morally obliged to
intervene i mean this is straight up
nazi [ __ ] like this is literally
like
you you can't catch
being transgender from people it's not
going to spread you [ __ ] idiot like
well also he's got it backwards it's
good to encourage people who are
confused yes it's good to make them feel
like they can be themselves
it's good to make them feel like
some [ __ ] creepy six-year-old is
gonna make a three-shot cam in his suit
questioning the legitimacy of you to
exist to be who you are
i mean this is this is basically and he
has said he's pro-conversion therapy so
this is basically
a conversion therapy philosophy which
says will gonna change who you are
who you are is not good we need to
change who you are
who you are is inherently evil we need
to change that
so you've actually got it backwards
you're leading with hate instead of
leading with compassion
that's what you're doing here mr uh dr
little dick
baldass
and his like purposeful
ignorance is coming off as stupid at
this point i think in the video totally
like you're still confused
you've just explained it to me totally
what the [ __ ] are you trying to say
it's it's yeah it's just it's dumb
but he's appealing to like a really low
common denominator of people yeah this
is actually the tweet this is the tweet
that happened recently and this is the
one that made me
erase those
um
episodes and this one kind of went under
the radar but he says he called
conversion therapy moral grandstanding
justin trudeau outlawed conversion
therapy in canada jordan peterson called
it moral
grandstanding and i was like man hell no
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
i'm not down with this guy anymore i'm
not even gonna make excuses for him yeah
you deleted the episodes about six days
later i believe thank you maybe
yeah thank you
well and also let's not forget jordan
called me out on twitter what's going on
ethan
the woke mob gotcha
what he and he asked me what did i say
that was so offensive and i gave him a
list a comprehensive list and he didn't
answer me
he did not answer me
weird so i don't get that i'm trying to
make a point i'm not a great debater or
intellectual or anything
i'm just surprised he didn't want to
engage me after he asked me
you know i was like am i going to answer
and i said you know what he asked me so
i'm going to give him
i'm gonna i'm gonna follow this through
he asked i'm gonna give him
do give him that um
luxury you know i'll tell you what
happened because she's so mad at twitter
for not
and he didn't answer me didn't even
acknowledge me
bucko
he still follows me though which is
awesome because i can i can comment on
his restricted tweets
utter carelessness of the twitter
organization
oh yeah this is the tweet he sent me
there was like such a banger
you will be held to a higher and higher
and soon impossible to maintain ethical
standard
by the very mob you currently wish to
please
then you will make a mistake and they
will devour you with glee
please take this warning seriously
i liked you
we were friends
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
um
i saw i know exactly did you see that
about the hair plug
yeah i knew that yeah it's funny
somebody in the comments candor pants
maybe he used grandma's pubes for the
hair plugs
they said
which
wow well you know we know it was a thick
she had thick hair yeah yeah thick matte
of hair paintbrush-esque
right and this hairline almost looks
painted on where's your grandma jordan
are you harvesting her pubes good tell
us the truth good catch good catch there
i saw my maternal grandmother sitting by
the bank of a swimming pool oh boy here
we go which was also a river
oh her general region was exposed dimly
it had the appearance where's the
grandma jordan we know what you're doing
she was stroking herself absent-minded
stop changing the size she walked over
to me with a handful of pubic hair
compacted into something resembling a
large artist's painting
she pushed this at my face this man is
sick i raised my arm several times to
deflect her hand
finally unwilling to hurt her or
interfere with her any further i let her
have her way i let her have she stroked
my face with the brush gently
like a child
here he said in his original tweet he
said what if i said precisely
that motivated your action and your
accusation precisely i said i said okay
you know what i'm gonna give him the
benefit of the doubt here
i'm gonna tell him exactly and he
[ __ ] bitched out baited [ __ ] i don't
know what's up
straight beta [ __ ] maybe he just missed
it
no he didn't miss it he's like a whole
damn discord everyone's losing their
mind on twitter where's he didn't miss
it
he's just a [ __ ] that dude's on twitter
12 hours a day you don't miss anything
yeah exactly
fact
and i would say
no
no
why
well
no first no why no
where am i confused no
no where am i right now
[Laughter]
no
why why well
where huh who
huh yes
huh what
exactly exactly
do no harm
as the hippocratic oath remember that
insists yeah well that's just your
opinion man
he's not doing harm you are dick second
it has been a matter of historical
consensus
that sins of omission are less egregious
than sins of commission thus leaving
someone with gender dysphoria no matter
how warranted and perhaps it is in a
very tiny minority of truly unfortunate
cases
to suffer the consequences like some of
you might be telling the truth yeah but
the vast majority after all of that
he's just like oh yeah gender dysphoria
is a real thing and it's a very sad
thing some of you are faithful
but
99 of y'all are fakers so wait so what's
the treatment because let's remember
again it wasn't that long ago where
homosexuality was considered a mental
illness guys
okay
so
let's hear what's the treatment for this
doctor the theoretical mismatch between
soul and body
is less of a risk ethically personally
socially and philosophically
than the extremely active intervention
that constitutes so-called gender
confirming another hated phrase surgery
you don't hate it that much look at your
hairline
i might also point out
that the trans surgery enterprise
is now a 300 million dollar per annum
growth industry rate of projected
expansion 15 percent per year projected
in
this is nuts big trends
this big trans is ruining our country
they're just cutting off genitals like
it's nothing
and rigging in the big bag they're
ripping the dog
someone keeps asking did did i watch
stranger things yeah it was awesome bro
the new season was sick we haven't
talked about the
second volume
so good we'll talk about on friday
because we've got no time but dude the
last two episodes i was like an hour and
a half one and then the other one two
and a half hours i was like oh my god
dude
daddy's feasting
you guys cannot spoil it for me i
promise i'm in season two what are you
waiting for are you catching up she's
we're gonna finish it you know what's
cool i think the new season was my
favorite of all of them
volume one i think was my favorite i
found it to be the character most evil
like it was the most villain like freddy
krueger type yeah i liked that i liked
it a lot i don't know can i just blow
can i just blow past the third season
because the third season is worth it
i like dinner no you need to see billy
man billy
yeah yeah
i quit mid-third i didn't get the whole
11's greaser side story that [ __ ] was so
weird and pointless but billy man that
guy [ __ ] i think that was season two
that was actually season two oh it was
yeah and that had that was stupid too oh
yes
season three was like 80s
season three was in the summer yep the
only one in summer with billy
i mean i've seen people in chat agree
that the fourth it's worth it to get to
the poor so maybe i'll just charge
through it i don't know because i i i
loved the first one and the second one
was okay but definitely was it's worth
it yeah fourth season and the third one
i i got like four episodes in and i was
like this is this is [ __ ] now i like
them all honestly but yeah i like the
first and fourth yeah it's a good watch
though it's not that bad it's a good
show you know
i agree i like billy as a character
though
all right let's finish this [ __ ] [ __ ]
increase by 2027 to 750 million dollars
per year an expanding enterprise in a
time of global uncertainty
time to invest both in the requisite
surgical skills and perhaps in any
industry associated with this vicious
and unconscionable i want some stock and
trans and who's selling stock buddy
i'm opening a clinic
i'm trying to get paid
by the way 300 million a dollar a year
industry in the whole country of medical
like
um verticals that's not that that's the
whole world was it not or was it oh if
it's the whole world that's that's
minutes it's dropping the bucket yeah
it's literally like a small business
i mean how much is like cancer treatment
is like a trillions you know what i mean
a year time to invest i mean even
like butt surgeries like one point
bbls
i just look butt
butt job yeah
what's bbl industry at let's see i guess
i'm saying 1.53 billion
there you go
bbl in this worldwide
is that that's got that is that cosmetic
surgery in general or is that that
specifically that's bbs
buttock augmentation market wow
it's a fraction of people getting
[ __ ] asked
300 million a year
is very small it's very small yeah of
course i mean that's really that's a
drop in the bus
medical expenses that's
that's not a big fast
business vertical you invest
time to invest well fad get in primarily
entangling has such things so often do
the youthful
and female
isn't that a concern
intersectionalists no
maybe until he understands this he
shouldn't be allowed to
get like his colonoscopies or something
right whatever his medical stuff is
let's put that on hold so that you can
fully understand this
you know
no more induced comas for uh drug
rehabilitation no
do you know what the benzo what's the
benzo treatment industry
like the the benzo recovery industry
size
i bet you it's way bigger
what even would i call that
rehabilitation just drug rehabilitation
i mean that's way more general but just
to give you an idea
let's see
it's got to be massive by the way we
there was another 50 uh
uh members donated and um
this time by somebody called mask off
and their icon is george soros so oh
i love you georgie
i love you georgie boy
let's get
[Music]
go
i'm seeing some crazy numbers around uh
42 billion a year yeah
drug rehab yeah i'm thinking that's just
the us actually yeah that that's that
makes sense to me you know
that's probably a mid there you know
that's probably like a mid-level mid a
medical vertical 300 million and this
guy's out here talking like it's a
conspiracy [ __ ] you just participated
in a 40 billion dollar
drug rehabilitation program
shut the [ __ ] up dude
what a hateful little demon he is
hair restoration is a 9.2 billion dollar
industry jordan
something he also participated in
a lot bigger than 300 million
nose jobs uh five billion nose jobs
alone five billion dollar industry
and based on his logic of uh the way
you're born and all that and being pride
prideful
same logic take your [ __ ] up nose lady
precisely god made that nose god made
that hairline
how dare you [ __ ] with god's creation
i could have sucked those tits before
they were cut off
by that butcher
post-coital
i could have got a poissoidal nut on
those titties
post-coital
shove
or ideology to scalpel
is that not a true moral hazard
and i'm not taking down that tweet or
acknowledging that my tweet violated the
twitter rules
up yours woke more or less
what a [ __ ] game so [ __ ] sick so
dope he's cool man
he's cool
he's a bad boy actually i give it a week
until that tweet's deleted he's fiending
up yours he's fiending like he fiends
for benzos i will never admit that i
broke the rules of a private company
he's coming out of his life he's in his
uh he's in his no nut era right now
because he can't demon retention he
can't do transphobia on the timeline
right now so he's he's not getting he's
losing it bro that seaman retention is
filling him up
we'll see who cancels who he's back
there twitter's a bro shut up dude he's
a grown-ass man i was so villainous this
is a grown this man has a phd listen to
this acknowledging that my tweet
violated the twitter rules
up yours woke moralists
we'll see who cancels who what does that
mean you want you want i'm going to
cancel twitter you want to participate
in cancel culture now
i i don't know what does that mean who
are you what a threat yeah it sure was a
threat no it was most definitely a
threat
we'll see who cancels through this is
not a bomb threat
against a specific address
i'm just saying
just saying
twitter's a rattle in the final analysis
and i have probably contributed to that
while trying to use understand and
master that horrible toxic platform
no doubt that i am obsessed with and
post spend 20 hours a day on 100 times a
day
pathological apologies for that and i'm
trying to learn but it's a relief in
some real sense to be banned
and i regard it under the present
conditions as a badge of honor
jordan peterson uncensored now on daily
wire plus
you couldn't even make it on to the
[ __ ] main daily wire he's on the plus
dude he's on the [ __ ] side oh no
they're smart that's the paying service
they want
this is huge money for them
i'm sure i'm sure they're breaking it in
from this man
oh yeah
it's awesome
well
there you have it we made it a great
thinker
he's thought his way he's thought of it
he's thought of everything
all right well there's a lot of stuff
here but and we're over it
there's a really good keemstar live fail
but we'll maybe watch it on friday did
you want to talk about the domino effect
of jordan peterson with dave rubin and
uh
oh dude well apparently he's back so i
don't know oh reuben's back loser
delete yeah a bunch of right-wing
grifters are trying to jump in on this
because they see like it's good
publicity
and so dave rubin like tweeted something
similar and then he got banned and then
made a whole thing
dave rubin is such a joke dude how does
that guy live with himself
but whatever um listen
yeah throwback to ben shapiro telling
dave rubin to his [ __ ] face that he
wouldn't go to his wedding because he's
a bad move
he wouldn't even bake him a cake look at
this this is the dave rubin bro this
this what are you doing bro okay so if
you wouldn't bake me a cake that's okay
and now because it's 50 50 i can't bake
you a cake which david's involved
putting that aside you can't have
david's kosher cake now um if we were
having an anniversary party would you
come if i was inviting all the crew that
we all know and we was just an
anniversary party we're just having a
party and uh and i'll even throw in some
kosher food for you to make sure you
don't have to bring your own you know
honestly i'd have to think about it i'd
have to think about it
so that's interesting to me yeah that's
that's that's interesting yeah you hate
me you actually hate it you just realize
wait wrong time is too late if you have
deep divisions with your spouse on these
issues i think that and you're looking
for the family anyway yeah then i think
that these are issues where building on
a bad foundation is bad also dave rubin
recently adopted a child with his
husband
and and um
i didn't didn't the guys on the daily
wireless buyer say that's like a sin
they don't agree he got attacked by all
of his fans because of course he did
yeah no he's loved that
what a useful idiot he is though so let
me okay so if you wouldn't bake me a
cake that's okay and wait i gotta find
the part of friendship by the way is
that like we go home at night we didn't
quite get to that i would be able to get
to with someone that you care all right
and then this is my view is you don't
gonna go out to dinner in the near
future
but an anniversary it was my anniversary
last year ah where's the timestamp this
is why i truly truly believe i believe
it now more than ever identity politics
is the biggest threat
that a free society has
and it's particularly our free society
because we've done the melting pot
better than anybody we did a melting pot
we did it right we blended this thing
right everyone still wants to come here
yeah i'm not sure ben loves that he
wants to unblend it for a better life
all these celebrities that always tweet
they're gonna leave they want apparently
everyone to come in and share in the
horrors so i think it's truly it is a
threat but yes i think we will get past
it and the reason i'm hopeful
is because when we look at all
that was about the anniversary but he
asked him about the wedding he says no i
would not go uh shapiro on there and
help
people change
would you come to my wedding he said no
let's see
um it says love this one's interesting
love the two of you you both converted a
socialist into a libertarian
conservative opera question
no and the reason i won't is because a
religious jew i
do not participate in activities that i
believe are sinful but again we live in
a free country and dave knows this dude
he just said you're going to hell
because you're gay and you [ __ ] break
bread with that man
what a [ __ ] he is dave reuben is a
soulless [ __ ]
useful idiot what a bottom of the barrel
[ __ ] he is i have to care what i think
yeah about sin and as long as i'm not
bothering dave i don't see why it's a
problem yeah so it's it will it's not a
problem if i think you're going to hell
and i think you're evil forgetful that's
not a problem we can still sit together
but well i no now if it was my choice if
i could eradicate every homosexual i
would you know but but that's not legal
and it's not possible so so so
it's fine
i mean it's not fine it's a sin but for
now you know for now for now does dave
have a husband yeah i mean like
okay are we friends yeah and are we
gonna go out to dinner sometime in the
near future yeah but but there's a
difference between me just being friends
with dave and me actively
participating in an event that i feel is
religiously sinful and i think it's how
most religious christians and most
religious jews feel and while that's
awkward yeah we're still friends in
spite of it which is why we're friends
if we could be friends in spite of it
that would be a bad thing well look when
i when i did your interview show which
by the way i mean yeah you jacked the
idea of an interview show from me it's
all right it's true but nobody's done it
before um
but you said that to me and and i truly
mean this like if you think what i'm
doing is sinful like i
i don't it sounds good but i don't care
right and then this is my view is you
don't have to care right it's a free
country right like that's the thing and
it's like
look
look
of course someone's going to go well
wait a minute if you really think his
marriage is sinful or saying of course
there may be a place that in the nature
of our friendship maybe that we can't
quite get to that i would be able to get
to with someone that didn't think for
sure that is very possible ben's like
for sure i i don't want to be close
friends with you you're gay and
that's just not cool
and
it goes both ways right like i then look
at you and i go
well why right that's a kid you don't
want me teaching your kid about the
nature of family perhaps right i mean
like
but you're probably a pretty good dad
like you know what i mean like david
you're such a [ __ ] why is it that we're
able to do this and most people can't do
this that's what i'm curious i think
it's beautiful that you [ __ ] hate
that i have no principle yeah and i have
no spine that i'll do anything for money
why can't everybody act like this i just
think it's beautiful that you can hate
my guts tell me i'm evil and that i
shouldn't exist and that you wouldn't
want to be close friends with me or
attend an anniversary party and that we
could just still be friends and i could
ignore all that
i don't care about any other gay
person's well-being
oh boy
this is the [ __ ] best one of my
favorite dave rubin moments home at
night and we can have our own lives
that's really and i think part of
friendship by the way is that like we go
home at night and we just have our own
lives yeah i'm not married to you right
like that's like my wife and i have to
agree on these issues you and i don't
have to agree on these issues in order
for us to share a common space together
and that's really the importance you
think your wife and you have to agree
anyway whatever [ __ ] that anyway that's
it
that's that
um
people are saying bobby and kalila broke
up that's not true is it they did wait
when did that happen
uh
today is what i'm seeing but wait where
was that where was that public the audio
for tiger belly went up
today their latest episode they're
breaking up yeah i guess so
i haven't heard it yet but you see
everybody in the chat spamming about it
sam was listening to it this morning i
think
i listened to bits and pieces of it they
don't really discuss it until the end of
the episode but
yeah wow that's shocking
i'm curious about the details of that
damn
that's crazy
but they're still gonna do
tiger belly together i doubt that
really come on
that's what they say now let's be honest
come on
it's not gonna last
there's no [ __ ] way they're gonna
keep doing the show together right
they just broke up i mean that's wishful
thinking it really is i mean who knows
they might get back together tomorrow
i don't know what are you laughing about
dan nothing nothing
all right that's it what do we do like a
10 hour episode i'm i gotta go three
hours long yeah we should wrap it up
thank you guys theoretically we have a
show tomorrow morning
i don't know like are you up for that i
don't know okay i don't know yet i'll
talk let's i'm gonna think about it okay
i'll talk about it off here but anyway
guys i'm glad that we had a nice day
here together oh ace fest people are
asking that's this weekend right
uh it sure is so yeah i mean um
look i can't wait i'm just so excited
about ace fest this weekend yep
more on that next week
i just can't wait
um anyway listen this is fun i'm glad
that we're back
i missed you guys we had a nice show
here today
i don't know if we're gonna have a show
tomorrow morning i'm gonna see um but
we'll definitely be here on friday
okay
sounds good
and thank you to george soros for wow
250
wow today
and everybody else i guess
we should mention there were lots of
people donating congratulations dan five
years of service yes
thank you here's to five more uh there
was a 100 donation from adam d
found out today i passed step one first
in a series of three grueling md
licensing exams oh and wanted to spread
love med students all over support the
compassion and policies y'all espouse
despite our current u.s nightmare keep
fighting for humanity papa bless and
love you all that is very nice
congratulations adam congrats what was
his name
adam deez nut
let's go right now baby
that one's for you love
thank you thank you
oh man all right guys so definitely see
on friday maybe tomorrow morning
um
i gotta rest my voice i'm concerned
about doing a show tomorrow it's very
hard on my voice that was kind of what i
was wondering because my throat's
undergoing a lot of pain right now
actually all right let's wrap it up
spaghetti
all right guys so you know anyway love
you all thanks for being here uh see ya
see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
you